representative broa are you able to take
notes for this
hearing yes Madam sure I am thank you
right so
the once the recording has started I
will announce the uh uh read the
script the recording has started thank
you Miss Marling you're
welcome as chair of the house Edna
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to ex executive order
20204 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee and
scheduled in the house calendar for
today an executive session may be held
on any Bill referred to the
committee please note there's no
physical location for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously
listen if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA
91a anyone has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600 or email HCS leg. state. n.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and
rescheduled all votes that are taken
during this meeting shall be done by
roll vote we will start by taking a roll
call attendance when you state your
presence also State whether there's
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required under the
right to no
present he's in the he's in the L I can
see him
right representative algro are you in
the L yes I am thank you represent
representative
Bailey present in the Ling thank
fellows okay representative
fer I am here at my home in Rochester
and my wife is in and out representative
goalie here at my home and my wife's in
the other room representative groda is
here in her home her husband is on the
he's home
lanara representative leus I'm present
in the committee room in the L thank you
representative
Maguire president of the committee room
O'Brien I am present I uh at my
residence in Nash and I am
Roy representative
Schmidt represent there you I'm in my
home office in I am am home at home in
my home office and over I am alone thank
you representative
Shu I am here at my home in pbrook uh
Schulz here in my home in conquer and my
husband will be in and out of the room
representative scitec will be here later
representative
yakubovich here at home alone in the
room
okay I'm just let me just see
representative fellows no Representative
lonara no representative Pearson
representative Roy representative Roy is
at at the chair's meeting he'll be in
later all right very good thank you R
call is
complete thank you I'd like to call the
prime sponsor representative
Moffett thank you madam chair it's great
to see everybody this morning uh for the
record I am uh state representative Mike
Moffett uh representing marac District 9
in the beautiful towns of canabury
and um okay I and others uh really hope
that you'll take some time to seriously
consider Constitutional Amendment
concurrent resolution number seven uh
and the notion of establishing a
lieutenant governor position for the
State of New Hampshire um currently at
least 43 other states already do have
Lieutenant govern Governors now I know
that is not a reason uh for us to
establish such a position but there is a
strong case uh for doing so which I'll
touch on briefly here uh and for doing
it the New Hampshire way uh
constitutionally uh our current line of
succession calls for the State Senate
President to replace the governor if
that's necessary and this has happened a
number of times uh most recently in 2016
when Senate President Chuck Morris uh
replaced Magie Hassen briefly when the
latter was sworn in as a US senator uh
Senate President Ralph Hoff did
similarly replac Jud Greg brief in
1992 when the latter was also sworn in
as US senator uh but please Ponder what
happened in
1982 when Senate President Vesta Roy uh
was sworn in as acting Governor upon the
death of U gallan now these two
individuals were of different parties uh
as were uh Senator Morrison and Governor
Hassen uh however uh gallon had just
been defeated in a re-election bit
actually having lost the office to John
cunu uh but assume that gallon had won
that election and then P before passing
away the people would have elected a
Democrat but then a republican would
have taken over and that presents some
major problems or potential issues that
really need uh some discussion and and I
think in Amendment um to have a state
senate or or a Senate President of one
party replace a governor of another
party creates many issues as I just said
does the new governor continue to serve
as Senate President uh you get into
separation of powers how could he or she
simultaneously or serve simultaneously
in both the legislative and executive
branches uh again separation of powers
issue that needs some discussion now
Senators moris Hoff and and Roy did not
resign their Senate seats when they were
sworn in as acting Governors but their
ten years of office as chief executive
were all very limited and they didn't it
created no long-term issues but what if
a Senate President needs to serve
several months as chief executive uh you
very conceivably could have someone who
sponsored a bill in the legislative
branch and then later uh signing the
same bill that they sponsored as chief
executive that conceivable or perhaps
vetoing a bill that they voted on as a
as a senator uh it utterly goes against
Civics 101 and and the separation of
powers and and New Hampshire is about
the only state that's in this unique
situation uh I ask you to ponder what
would have happened had God forbid uh
Republican Governor sinunu had been
struck by lightning in
2019 uh Democratic senator Don ASI would
have become governor to finish out his
term by
current current
Constitution uh now which she have
maintained sununu's existing staff or
replaced its members there's all kinds
of uh questions like that that uh
fortunately we've never really had to
yet uh deal with but we need to to think
about what would have happen with regard
to running the Senate um good question
could she again ser simultaneously in
the legislative and executive branches
uh I don't think so uh she would have
been sworn in as acting governor and and
so does she resign her seat is in the
Senate uh you know that would
disenfranchise about five% of New
Hampshire citizens um and again but
Senators Roy Hoff and mois just to site
three recent examples uh stayed in the
Senate and were sworn in as acting
Governors that's a problem um now New
Hampshire is one of uh only two states
in the country that have Governors who
serve two-year terms so that mitigates
the the situation somewhat but action is
still needed uh perhaps if a state
Senate President was elevated to
Governor they would resign uh their seat
but what if they don't want to resign
their seat um I things to really think
about so Madam chairman this is
potentially uh a serious situation it's
not just an issue it's not just an issue
in other states but it is here potential
serious problem so I many of us think
there's a need for Action here and that
action involves uh amending our
constitution to create a lieutenant
governor position but we should do it
the New Hampshire way we should have in
our view a citizen lieutenant governor
the way we have citizen legislators like
us uh cacr 7 calls for the lieutenant
governor to receive the same salary as
that Senate President which is $125 a
year so this could be a wonderful
example of improving government in the
best way think about it essentially
doubling our gubernatorial Manpower and
virtually no cost our governor as you
know gets countless
invitations more than he or she could
ever begin to accept uh is a whole
scheduler in the governor's office um
building dedications ribbon cuttings uh
testimonials funerals School visits on
and on uh a lieutenant governor could
double the
productivity in the capacity of the
governor's office to be a presence and
support so many things around the state
that would be U wonderful
and again at basically no cost according
to our proposed CA CR7 or 125 bucks so
the line of succession would be cleaner
New Hampshire voters would now vote for
a ticket and be assured that the state
would avoid chaos that would occur head
if AE a governor gets struck by
lightning which we hope would never
happen but we need to think about it um
especially if the Senate President is of
a different party which has happened a
couple times I pointed out already uh
the succession issue addressed by ccr7
is
nonpartisan is there is no way to know
which parties will control which offices
in the future now now some will argue
we've never done that
before or I mean I know can I can hear
it now I've already heard it or we've
gotten along fine without a lieutenant
governor for Jordan 40 years so don't
need to start now or just because every
other State as a lieutenant governor
doesn't mean we need to have one but
those I think are all flawed arguments
and hopefully when this measure goes to
Executive session uh can be
appropriately discussed and and and
refuted uh by the way there's growing
interest in this uh there's going to be
a CED monitor piece on it later this
week so it's something that is getting
more and more attention just FYI so
anyway uh I I think we think this is a
really great proposal that improves the
line of succession improves the
productivity and capacity of the
governor's office it precludes the
potential chaos that would result if the
governor needed to be replaced Midway
through a term and all for $125 a year
so I think we can do this and I think we
should do this so thanks for your time
I'd be happy to take any any questions
Schmid thank you madam chairman welcome
Colonel Moffett uh nice to see you uh
other than on the mound pitching
softball at us Democrats um um and uh so
I see you've done a lot of thinking
about this and uh hypothesize but I'm
wondering is it realistic to uh to
expect someone to
assume position where
they you haven't given much example of
what they would have to do um and uh you
don't set that out it would be quite
different from uh New Ham New
Hampshire's current situation where uh
the Senate President is already
appointed there is no nothing analogous
to uh the United States Vice President
who uh who uh presides over the Senate
um and has that responsibility and there
is no Senate President except Senate
President Pro Tim so is it reasonable to
expect that a person serving in this
role would would do so in any meaningful
way for uh $125 a year that's my
question first question sure absolutely
and a in a great question uh the answer
is yes I mean look at all of you look at
all of us uh would would this position
would it be hard to fill this position
uh absolutely not I think uh there's a a
great Universe of people uh who uh could
uh balance a ticket so to speak uh look
at us uh uh by as I say the New
Hampshire way we we we are citizen
legislators and and I think whoever a
governor might pick as a running man
Governor uh I think they is as I said a
wide universe of possibilities and uh
and and to what what would they do we've
heard all these quotes about the vice
president vice presidency but I think
it's very exciting to uh I mean picture
the next Governor whoever he or she may
be from whichever party and think about
uh you know who they might want to have
as a running mate to augment to balance
to complement uh the skills or whatever
the current governor has so to answer
your question yes uh I think there's uh
all kinds of people who would be
wonderful candidates to attended
Governor would want to do it and then it
would be up to the governor really to
decide uh if they want to make the
lieutenant governor energy Zar or
whatever but uh lots of
possibilities followup
briefly thank you Madame chair uh so
have you costed out what it would what
it would actually cost for uh a
lieutenant governor position because uh
the person would be essentially uh very
handicapped if not useless if uh if they
were all there by themselves to the
degree they have to have the staff uh
now you're talking about uh you know
additional space and also cost the staff
is not going to work for $125 a year
another good question I think that uh
lieutenant governor if there was one or
hopefully will be one I I think they
basically all they would need would be a
desk really in in the phone uh the the
current executive chief executive staff
the government staff would would stay
the same and this would just be uh an
addition to the staff who would be first
line of succession and would understand
and know what going on in that office
and uh so I see no uh other than $125 in
in a desk and maybe a phone line if that
uh I see no uh necessary major expenses
to implement this thank you you
representative
Shu thank you madam chair
good morning representative M
morning I am not sure if I missed it but
I didn't see any um thing in the
um amendment to upgrade this person's
salary should they become governor uh
and have to take that job for a long
term what would be your intention
for at that point I doubt
sure sure uh I'll tell you when Senator
mois became acting governor for however
many days she uh he immediately this is
already a practice he immediately
received uh thousands of dollars in
salary for the the time that he served
as acting chief executive so so that's
already in place representative uh
lieutenant governor is elevated as his
past practice they would be paid uh the
full salary of the governor follow
follow up follow up thank you um okay so
you're saying that that's uh been
practic however do you not feel that it
should be incorporated in the
law uh I don't know that it's necessary
because of past practice uh but uh if if
this this is the committee's bill now
and if if there was a desire to uh
codify that or to confirm that uh that
certainly uh would be easily done if you
wanted to do
that thank
you representative
fellows thank you madam chair um
representative M um I was a little bit
late getting on today so I apologize if
you've already address this but on the
first page on line five I see that um
whose title shall be his Excellency I
was wondering if maybe we could address
that at the same time
sure uh great Point uh working with oess
in in the the current uh uh
constitutional article that covers
succession uh his Excellency I think uh
is is an outload of term that's an
excellent point I think uh it should say
his or her Excellency uh I I agree great
great
Point representative
Schulz thank you madam chair I'd like
this um UNC concept
um so for what it's worth I worked for
the lieutenant governor of Kentucky
before um don't you think they would
need at least a scheduling staff person
I know you mentioned that the
governor uh that person's staff could do
what would be needed for the lieutenant
governor but have you looked at what
sort of Staff uh Lieutenant Governors
typically have and my second question is
uh do you know how many Lieutenant
Governors are elected separately in
other states because that's an
interesting concept
too sure good good questions uh I know
there are at least 43 other uh
lieutenent Governors and there's a
breakdown some run as a ticket which we
propose here and some are uh elected
separately uh if you go back in history
you might recall that our country it
used to be the vice president was the
one who get the second most and that
didn't work out so that was fixed uh in
terms of Staff uh we or the sponsors uh
really don't Envision or want really
given I say the New Hampshire way uh to
give the uh liutenant Governor's staff
like uh the lieutenant governor
Massachusetts has I me right now we have
no lieutenant governor and I think the
New Hampshire way would be as I said to
pay him
$125 and just have he or she aug
the current staff so I as I said I think
uh the current scheduler could C
certainly easily uh you know plug in the
lieutenant governor for uh a bridge
dedication up in
coldbrook which I it would be wonderful
because uh so so many invites come to
the governor's office and most of them
answered I think it would be good Civics
it would be good service uh and I don't
see any need for staff I know I'm
somebody who worries about growing
believe Me growing bureaucracy and
growing government and I know some folks
from my side initially looked at me and
said what are you doing and again I hope
you look at the New Hampshire way that
we we propos here uh which would involve
no new staff just a desk and uh using
existing
staff thank you thank you representative
Moffett are there other questions from
the
committee seeing none I call repres
Madam chair Madame chair yes
representative Judy
please go ahead you hear me okay thank
you Madame
chair good morning and I I understand
really clear your
idea um but uh we don't know if we need
it or not what type of uh requirements
or qualification this person need to
become uh the rant
Governor
mer the the qualifications would be the
same as uh for governor um uh and beyond
that uh again I think it's exciting uh
Bey they'd have to obviously satisfy the
same age residency requirements as the
government beyond that uh they could be
any anyone it could be any of you uh if
the next Governor wanted you to get that
$25 raise and become lieutenant governor
uh so in terms of qualification same as
what's in place now and uh in the duties
governor mer mer
Merc
J representative fellows do you have
another question um I'm just since we
have a couple of minutes um Madam chair
I was just wondering if I can get a
better explan of why there's an
assumption that he only needs he or she
only needs
$125 and won't have any duties assigned
and doesn't need fellows representative
Moffett covered that the beginning of
the hearing and we do have two other
people who wish to testify so I would I
would rather hear from them first
representative that's fine
representative Horgan
oh thank you very much Madam chair I am
representative Timothy Horan I represent
cord County's District Six the towns of
Durham and Madbury and I've been a to
H Hampshire for 13 years now we've been
struggling the whole time to a certain
constitutional office which is few of
any function well struggling is over
dramatic where most people are oblivious
to the issue of the officer probate but
it's it's um and I think you know
basically it's the nominal office with
um only a few more d duties in this one
would have if we passed the cacr but I
think it's dangerous have an elective
office with no power because even a
nominal office can be abused um actually
none of the counties have had much
trouble since 2009 reg probate they've
had trouble with the County Treasurer
who paid a few thousand dollar and then
also the County Attorney is actually a
full-time full-time job with a real
salary but still um i' I've I've tried
various legislative inies that when
restoring some of his powers or or that
eliminating it so once we create this
constitutional office it's going to be
very hard to get rid of it um I actually
didn't pick up in the Texas C ever that
representative M it and the sponsors
intended to pay the lieutenant governor
just $125 a year I think um even though
I've been um getting 100 working for
$100 a year for 13 years now I I frankly
I don't think that's a good idea I think
that's a issue out a little bit outside
the perview of the CHR but I think
actually we need to move towards paying
ourselves an actual salary So like um
you know if you don't want to take the
salary you can donate a charity I
actually don't I did they pay the Senate
President $125 a year or the lieutenant
governor but and actually
uh think my testimony further on I'll
deal with that issue but anyway it's
it's a new constitutional office the
office of lieutenant governor the office
has no specific duties at all aside from
waiting around for the governor to
become incapacitated die or resign
and but Most states do have a lieutenant
govern governor and that liutenant
Governor serves as the uh president of
the Senate as well just much like the
vice president United States so they
usually don't vote except when there's a
uh when there's a tie so um throughh we
do it differently we have we elect our
own the Senate elects it own president
who's first in line the action Governor
first we heard several times um it
hasn't happened times I really don't
think it's been problematic I don't
think it would have been a big deal even
if uh Senator Susi had for some reason
become the acting governor in place of s
I actually don't think that would have
been a problem maybe partially I'm bias
because I like I I like Senator Susi I
think she's a great Senator and also in
terms of changing the parties most most
of the voters who will Vote for This
liutenant Governor are are the largest
blocker Undeclared you like aren't a
member of either party so I don't think
they'd necessarily be troubled by that
we might actually uh might actually have
people voting for a Democrat on for the
governor and then a republican on the
lieutenant governor balance things out
we're g a lot of Voters are going to do
that but I don't know about running's a
ticket we've never elected people we've
never done that except for the president
of the United States which is a
different case I I really don't know how
that works I'm not sure if that's even a
good idea I think actually uh most of
Voters would prefer to uh you know have
an allart approach to most most them
would at least have the option to choose
one part's Governor the other part's
lieutenant governor um so if so I
certainly think we if we probably should
should consider if you want to go
through this at all giving the
lieutenant govern some constitutional
function such as presiding over the
senate or chairing the executive Council
or even this is sort of a slightly uh
choking comment taking over the few
duties to the 10 Cy current registers
probate um but we do that we need a
different Amendment we need much longer
Amendment um and this uh version of the
amendment makes no provision for an
acting lieutenant governor as a vacancy
in that offer it's merely Rising Senate
President followed by several officers
would be next in line to serve as acting
Governor but we you know there's no
provision here of an acting lieutenant
governor there's also um probably we
probably have to amend several other
articles of the Constitution to
accommodate this new office and of
course also we'd have to pass a lot of
Statute law too but although if the
amendment passes it would take effect um
guess on a convening day in January 2022
and then the new then the next general
election is until 2024 because that does
give us a couple years to sort that out
but that's still um anyway so I'm going
to say finally this is Advocate D
General Court would as I just said have
to make some changes to statute law
doing some changes would would cost
money I know in Hamp ways to do things
without spending any money without
giving people any resources without
hiring enough staff for institutions to
run I know that's a New Hampshire way um
seemen by but I don't think that's
workable for liutenant governor I don't
think we'll have a hard time I just
don't think that's going to work uh so
you need to be paid a salary I
definitely don't think $125 president
Senate a realistic salary even for the
Senate President for GR new office
receipt if I think they probably would
certainly should probably be end up
being paid at Great ll in the salary
schedule in RSA 94 col one A and B and
of course you all know that by heart
probably probably don't know it by but
the Commissioners other officials paid
at those grades which just like the
Attorney General the commissioner of
Education etc etc they currently make a
little more less than $140,000 a year
plus benefits I believe I'm on I agre I
agree with representative Schmidt R red
mouth that this liutenant Governor is
going to need a staff G need a chief of
staff at a minimum even um even
president Morris has a uh has
a as a staff who are all of whom are
actually paid real salaries he's the
only person uh in the Senate president's
office who does the job for $125 a year
so he needed Chief of Staff probably
chief so the chief of staff will
probably need staff You Know Chief of
Staff is probably need a staff and even
if we do it all just the governor's
staff I'm that's more work for the
Governor's staff so I'm I'm thinking at
a bare
minimum if we pass this taxpayers be on
the hook for at least a quarter million
dollars a year probably a lot more
especially if we're paying this person
mileage to go around around to C Brook
open Bridges and stuff so that's uh
that's definitely into the six figures
and Poss the seven figures to create
this job which is and I'm not
necessarily against creating jobs even
government job I'm not necessarily
against paying uh the lieutenant
governor staffers real salary or even
paying the lieutenant governor real
salary I don't think that's a bad thing
but um it's still a lot of money to pay
for an office with has nothing in
particular to do I mean even though
obviously Lieutenant government will
find things to do the governor give them
projects and stuff I you know I think
that's still a lot of money to pay from
office which has no set Duty so I I I
definitely my recommendation is just
find this inexpedient to legislate um I
mean you thank you representative Horgan
will you take a question oh absolutely
broa
muted I saw her asked a question but I
couldn't hear it because he's muted so
he's muted yes please unmute yourself
representative broa do you no longer
have a question I do I have a I I was
muted I didn't realize it um
representative muet you say in your
testimony that you uh think that having
um a lieutenant govern having the
governor being replaced by a a person
outside of that their party is a problem
why is that why do you see that as a
problem well that's how things are now
and we I cited two examples of that has
happened uh Republican replacing a
Democrat and a Democrat replacing
Republican for the short term uh the
reason I think it's an issue long term I
mentioned this already in terms of Staff
uh if for example if Senator Susi had
had to replace governor cuno in 2020 or
2019 um you know a staff is is personal
to the chief executive so the qu the
concern is that uh would the new
governor mesh with the staff uh maybe
not uh would the new governor uh replace
all the staff so that's the concern
about uh if a member of the if the state
Senate President was of one party and
the governor was of another having a
ticket removes that um that
problem thank
you other
questions seeing none excuse me
I if if it's a concern that the parties
change before you established this
office couldn't you just work the
succession such that it skips over
parties well the statute is in place now
I don't know I mean if something
happened right now to Governor shunu God
forbid uh by the con institution uh
Senate President Morris has to become uh
he is first in line in succession so I I
don't know how we could skip over uh
anyone if they were of of a contrasting
Party part answer that this is actually
my question time but um parties aren't
mentioned really in the Constitution at
all that's something that's evolved over
the years and um also it's not even
necessarily the case that a Senate
President of the same party might
necessarily take the same approach as
the uh exg Governor that that's not
umly like say Chuck Morris became the
action Governor he he has a different
approach to things in cuno for example
alth that would probably not be you know
probably wouldn't create much probably
tested that
one other questions for representative
okay thank you uh Madam chairman and the
members of the committee uh I'd like to
say I'm I'm Alvin C I live in lden and
I'm in favor of this bill uh my uh
biggest concern uh that I think this
addresses is if there is a
longterm replacement of the governor
that um if the Senate President is
filling in for an extended period of
time that there's a conflict where the
Constitution really wanted the
legislative branch to be separate from
the executive branch and that this
muddies the water there um also um as
far as a technical thing within the bill
itself on page one lines 20 to 22 where
it lists the
qualifications for the governor it
probably should also say the governor
and lieutenant governor um that would be
on line 22 after the word Governor Ed
and lieutenant
governor um the other concern I have
about this bill is the text that has to
be printed on the ballot there's two and
a half pages it's 82 lines in in the
bill that has to be printed on each and
every ballot throughout the state um and
that's a lot of reading for somebody who
hasn't planned ahead for U for this I
don't know whether that um instruction
to the B uh for on the ballot can be
summarized and and made a little more
brief or
not uh and the the last thing I wanted
to mention in several cases on
U uh lines
uh all 19 and 22 it talks about uses the
word
plurality in the 1912 constitutional
convention uh the Constitution
originally had the word majority in that
place now it has
plurality
and in the case of line
22 having the word
plurality um kind of makes the rest of
the sentence uh redundant or ineffective
because the plurality
uh you can get a plurality if if at
least one ballot is cast for an office
because plurality is
simply the most whoever gets the most
votes uh rather than a majority which
required um over 50% of the of the votes
and there was provision in there and
that's what all the rest of that was was
how the U legislature would
select the governor if there wasn't a
majority um while that
not necessarily a problem for
this uh particular amendment I just
thought I'd bring that up since you're
having to uh make changes in that
sentence that's a little bit poorly
structured now anyway and that's all I
have I'd be glad to answer any
questions thank you representative Shu
has
one thank you Madame chair um Mr C I I
just want to be sure you're listed in
the sign as supporting the bill however
a lot of the language inconsistencies
that point out almost indicate that you
are opposed to it in the current form uh
can you clarify for sure your position I
am in favor of having a lieutenant
governor there is some wording issues in
the proposed amendment that may make it
a little bit awkward for the voters or
for uh eventual uh
implementation and U I leave that to the
committee's wisdom to uh resolve thank
you is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on cacr
7 all right seeing none I will close the
public
hearing and open the public hearing on
Madam chair before we open the public
meeting May I finish the Roll Call to be
sure that on audio we have everyone
because I think everyone's come
in um representative
fellows EXC I will open the public
hearing because we're having a little
difficulty with our sound the the staff
is here to take care of it we will take
a short break while we hopefully fix our
sound issues okay thank
you Jack Jackie I'm home
alone okay
and I think I see uh representative
Pearson yeah I'm here how's this uh
how's this microphone working out good
excellent representative scitec I see
him in the
lobby I mean in the lb
sorry and representative Lara you're
home I am yes and everybody is home from
school zooming in N oh
great and I don't see representative Roy
yet
bit did you just ask somebody to talk
yes please okay
we can do that over this is I presume
some you want someone to talk over Zoom
land yeah just so I can
the I'm not sure what you said but I'm
sure it was
[Laughter]
right we do hear a quite a bit of
background noise and I'm not sure what
that's what that's
[Music]
sorry I'm sorry uh did you want me to do
something yeah I just want you to talk a
little bit just so we can see if there's
any
feedback okay I can I can ramble a
little bit up here youan I'm um amble on
like Le Zeppelin well maybe you can help
me
representative without a topic it's a
little more difficult for me to uh uh
keep it going talking about lead
Zeppelin is that really go ahead talk
about Le lead Zeppelin well we could
talk about uh let's see so 50th
anniversaries of things let's see it's n
it's 20 let's see 1971 what the heck
happened
then well actually right now we're we
got guys on the moon 50 years ago
today collecting things I think alen
Shepard hits his golf ball in the moon
tomorrow it's either today or tomorrow
50 years
ago 1971's when the United States went
off
gold we went off a gold in 71 is that
what you said
Matt the sound is really good it sounds
like yep uh they stopped it because uh
France is importing so much of our gold
they want they didn't want us to uh lose
it all because uh anyway yeah 71 Nixon
took us off gold
Ryan did you have
something yeah the sound is coming
really good it sounds like
representative PE it sounds like your
mic gain is too high my mic gain yeah I
just how about now if I just pull the
mic away from my
face the problem is coming from yours I
believe yeah I just I I don't understand
how I'm having the problems with the
headset your you can um you can turn
down your mic
Bo got it all right I'll see if I can do
that that down like 10 well there's no
real
number thank you should switch back to
your other headset this is poorer sound
quality from you than we've had in the
past and the sound quality is relatively
crappy from virtually everybody today so
I think it's a bug in the
network so Peter you're saying this is
worse than what I was just on my laptop
microphone I think this is not as good
yeah you sound like a helicopter pilot
from the
news with the headset just so you
clearly I could hear him very clearly
setup it's just has a weird like I don't
know what the word is for a tin TI i n
teny kind of
news we should be
good thank you sir one other quickie can
you set that to to speaker view so that
res resuming our hearing then I don't
see representative Wier on on the
attendance
list Madam chair are you in need of
someone just to introduce it
that since I'm familiar with
it proceed thank you thank you madam
chair and thank you members of Edna I
for the record I am representative
Pearson Rockingham district 6 in Derry H
Bill 298 is a bill that we saw last
session in reference to the
spot on the aviation board
for what what technically is called an
unmanned
aircraft which we would all generally
know as a drone U this went through
Committee in the prior session there was
really uh very little issue with this
and got caught up in the Omnibus
Senate I think it's pretty
straightforward it's just it's just um
it's just adding a additional person to
the in to The Advisory Board and that's
board thank you uh Madam chairman can I
interject there is a phone number
somebody is phoning in and it appears to
be a number that um could very well be
representative Wier and and um if he
could only if he could raise his hand by
hitting star nine on his phone we would
know for sure I can look him up too real
quick to see if that's true well we
can't see the entire phone number but
the last three digits yeah that's him
that's him yes yep it's Kenny whoever
that phone number is you have can you
hear me please unmute yourself and
identify
yourself can you hear me yes St six all
right representative Ken Wier is on this
phone i' I've tried 10 times to get onto
the website I put in everything I could
think of and assigned in it three times
and nothing seems to go
through well you're here now please uh
We've introduced the bill please explain
it to
us thank you very much Madam chair um
this is represent Ken wild Rockingham 13
introducing uh House Bill 298 this is
almost the same bill that was passed out
of this Committee in the last session as
house bill2 22 it passed out of the
house on a Voice vote the Senate tabled
it along with many other will we are
still in need of having an experienced
drone or unmanned aircraft system
operator on the aviation users Advisory
Board this year the mercus center
released a report titled which states
have prepared for the Drone industry a
50 state report C release 2.0 the report
details the Drone services are being
tested and permitted progress in the
United States has been slow in part
because of a lack of clarity about the
federal and state roles of drone and
airspace management they rate New
Hampshire is number
26 the aviation users Advisory Board is
a valuable agency when it comes to
recommending Aviation policy or
legislation with the new developments
coming to us we rely on this agency to
work on policy for our state in order
for the board to be fully informed they
need a permitted drone operator on the
board because of frequent changes to the
federal air regulations dealing with the
permitting of the Drone operators the
amendment that has been offered I hope
it has come to the committee changes the
reference to 14 CFR section
10753 at seek to 107 at seek where at
seek is Latin
etq for at se quentes which is a legal
term for and the
following thus if the CFR makes minor
minor changes to the section and
renumbers or add something we will not
have to change our state law if we make
this amendment to
107.5
10753 at se thank
you oh I mean 107 at se I think that's
the language I get it there are some
questions do you will you be answering
them
Shu thank you madam chair um
representative Wier you say uh this bill
is almost the same as last year's uh is
that proposed amendment that you spoke
of is that the only change from last
year that's my belief yes I think that's
the only change thank
Schmidt thank you madam chair uh
representative wer um uh we have in
straford County one of the outstanding
drone operators in the state I believe
um skip christenberry you may know him
uh I would certainly uh wonder whether
um we are holding back our industry in a
significant way uh and preventing it
from taking uh uh a bigger part of our
economy if is it your opinion that um
that uh there are any states where
the they have gotten farther out ahead
of us and where you see the kind of
development that's possible uh with a an
appropriate um you know participation
such as your bill
suggests um I would go by that mercus
report and I would be happy to try to
link it to the committee and and send it
on um so that you could all have a
chance to read it as reference this bill
and it would tell you some of the
suggestions that are that are uh have
been done in the other states that
theyve rate higher and that would be a
good way to start thank you for the
question thank you there are no other
Lambert hello can everybody hear me yes
see if I can do a video too as well
there you are
good morning Madam chair and members of
the committee my name is Trisha Lambert
and I'm the administrator for the New
Hampshire Department of Transportation
Bureau of
Aeronautics um I I would thought I would
come briefly just to uh to say that I
that the bureau is in support of this
bill um uas or drones have been a very
big part of our life here at the
department both from a regulatory View
and as well as the department um Contin
beginning to use drones uh for our
day-to-day work um to make it cheaper
safer faster um and all those things
um
I will also tell you that we are just as
a compliment to the aviation users
Advisory Board um the uas position is
definitely very needed each person on
the board represents a facet of Aviation
uh that provides um the necessary
up-to-date information to the department
um so that we can continue to be up on
Aviation issues as they happen um
currently we do not have anybody on the
board that has this type of experience
so we are in very much support of that
um position to be part of this Aviation
users Advisory Group um
board um it was mentioned earlier that
the aviation users Advisory Board is
advisory in nature they are ALS O A
hearings board so if you were to have
some type of a situation regarding a
drone that would require a hearing um
this would be the board that would
eventually hear it after it proceeded
through the process so they also um are
part of that role as well um I know
there's um I believe other members that
like to speak but I'm thank you very
much for allowing me to testify and I'd
be happy to answer any
questions thank you Miss Lambert are
seeing none thank you very
you can you hear me yes oh very good
thank you good morning um and thank you
for allowing me to testify U Madam
chairwoman Maguire and the committee
members um I just will Echo a little bit
of what Trisha just spoke about uh the I
am a member of the aviation users
Advisory Board I am the vice chair um
and I also work for plain sense Inc
which is a fractional ownership program
operating out of Portsmith so I'm a
member as a corporate Aviation um
constituency and it's important for
folks to understand that this board does
have two roles does have an advisory
role and it does have um a hearing role
and appeals hearing role and we're
finding ourselves you know grappling
with uas related issues for which the
current membership doesn't have a lot of
uh expertise and experience in order to
be able to uh perform its advisory role
certainly to um the Bureau of
Aeronautics and we are also similarly
concerned that U as we go down the road
with an ever expanding and and complex
new area of Aviation that we're going to
find ourselves
um in the position of having to uh
adjudicate if you will um on an appeals
hearing on a topic for which we don't
have a lot of um exposure and experience
so I can't uh
overstate our concern and our belief
that it's going to be very important for
us and for the state to have an
additional member to this board to deal
directly with uas and give uh good input
and exposure um for the board to that
industry
um I think that's all I need to say uh
again thank you for your uh for this
opportunity for me to
testify thank you will you answer a
Schmidt thank you madam chair Miss Bato
uh given the fact of your testimony that
you're uh you don't have much expertise
and this is an area where expertise is
very significant um how do you help
yourselves i i i preface my question
with stating that again that straford
county has an outstanding drone operator
uh and I've learned a tremendous amount
from conversing with him uh are you
seeking advice from skilled individuals
such as uh Mr christenberry with regard
to issues that come before you involving
um drone
operations I I think that most of us are
familiar with someone in the industry we
certainly do um talk to folks in the
industry about issues and I think one of
our members actually has gotten his um
operator's license um but it's not quite
the same as having somebody on the board
with you to hear the issues particularly
at the meetings uh real time and have
the opportunity to uh weigh in on those
real
time thank you
okay is there anyone else who wishes to
okay seeing none I'll will close the
hearing
[Music]
and leus would you introduce House Bill
298 is the one we just heard oh you're
wasn't prepared for that but let's see
what I can do just just say you're
introducing it and you won't take
questions all right I'm introducing
House Bill 302 it's a relative to
creation and use of electronic records
by government
agencies uh there probably better people
to answer questions than
me thank you representative leus
uh we'll keep an eye out for
representative obber other there
uh I'd like to
ask Margaret birds from the um Municipal
next good morning Madame chair and
members of the committee uh my name is
Margaret Burns I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and we are here in support
of House Bill
302 by way of a little background of how
this bill came to be over the past
several years many municipalities have
been transitioning from paper to
electronic documents as well as
signatures as a way of becoming more
efficient and saving money then due to
the pandemic the need for operating
virtually and electronically became even
more apparent and even more widespread
among political
subdivisions however in reading the
applicable law which is RSA 294
D it would appear that political
subdivisions have authority to use
electronic records and signatures only
if standards have been already adopted
by the Secretary of State's office and
the department of Information Technology
I think at best the language in 294 e is
ambiguous standards have been adopted
for the state many years ago but there
are currently no standards in place for
for cities towns and other political
subdivisions as a result shortly after
the state of emergency was declared um
Governor sonunu included in emergency
order 23 Authority for municipalities to
use electronic records and signatures
despite um the ambiguity currently in
294 D after that nhma and our board
chair at the time Shawn Mulholland who
was also in the hearing this morning
contacted commissioner gouet of the um
Department of Information Technology we
talked about the issue and we worked on
the language that is now House Bill 302
to rectify the problem House Bill 302
would clarify that municipalities may
use electronic records and signatures
even once the state of emergency has
ended and even without specific
standards being created for
municipalities by the state um in a
nutshell what the bill does is it
continues to allow doit to adopt
standards but it also makes clear that
even in the absence of those standards
political subdivisions cities towns
Village districts Etc can use electronic
records and signatures so that they may
continue to engage in that practice um
even after this state of emergency is
over so we think this is a very
important
clarification in the law and of course
I'm happy to take any
questions thank you are there any
questions
leus um in uh part two section B there's
a couple of places where must is
replaced by should I'm wondering what
the uh purpose of that is I mean because
if standards are created it sounds like
uh you they wouldn't need to be followed
in that case I think uh the the
reasoning behind changing some of the
words the must to should as well as the
shall determine being changed to May
develop standards is to make clear that
um the department of Information
Technology can still adopt those
standards but even in the absence of
those standards municipalities can use
electronic records and signatures so
they're not waiting on the development
of those standards um in order to have
the authority to use electronic records
and signatur so that was the reasoning
behind changing some of those must and
questions thank you very much thank you
mhand I'll just uh add to what uh
Margaret is already stated I'm not going
to repeat all of those things uh
basically the opportunity to develop
standards has been in place since
September 11th of 2001 quite some time
ago and those agencies have not had the
opportunity to do that probably because
they don't have the resources be able to
do that they have developed standards
for state agencies but not for counties
and municipalities this uh these changes
again will allow us to continue to work
together with doit Secretary of State's
office and admin Services um should they
get into a position where they can
create standards and we hope that they
do we want to work with them we are
partners with them and we help make
these changes in partnership with doit
so I think this is just an opportunity
for us to continue to work to work
together but again those agencies
apparently are not in a position at this
point to be able to develop those
standards and this allows us to use
electronic records and electronic
signatures which of course we have been
doing as municipalities and counties for
a very long time anyway and this just
language thank you Mr mahalan are there
committee I don't see any so thank you
for your
testimony is there anyone else who
[Music]
so uh we have a few minutes before our
next hearing begins at 11: so does
Roy 24
2 is there is there a
second we couldn't hear him Madam chair
we didn't hear it I'm sorry could you
repeat what was the motion the motion
was House Bill 274 inexpedient to
legislate by representative Roy I'll
second seconded by representative leus
do you wish to speak to your motion
yes this is the that um St
all is that better oh yeah definitely
this is the bill um having the state
pick up a portion of the retirement
funding for the municipalities I'm
moving this bill in expedient to
legislate because I believe at this
particular point in time um the state
has no no additional funds to even uh
entertain this and the only way the
state would be able to raise funds would
be to increase business taxes which
would crush our small businesses at this
time so while the concept behind it may
at some point in the future have Merit
cently it's uh not feasible at all thank
you person black to speak to your second
is there anyone else who would like to
motion Madam chair yes representative uh
if I may speak representative O'Brien
please
do thank you madam chair uh with the
deepest respect to my fellow Comm uh
committee members are making the
recommendation of I but the statement
goes that the state
cannot afford it in general
terms well here's the problem
municipalities
can't uh support it in the situation of
my constituents a city of approximately
100,000 people the city of
nassor is paying just in pension costs
4.4
million I don't know about you I lost
$100 on the Super Bowl last night but
$4.4 million is very hard for the
taxpayers to uh feel now this all let's
step back retro back a bit the state
used to pay 35% towards a pension cost
this is not asking to go back to the 35%
years this is just asking to assist uh
the taxpayers of your communities
because if you have one police officer
that's in the New Hampshire retirement
system one teacher that is in the New
Hampshire retirement system or one fir
fighter in the New Hampshire retirement
system or perhaps some of your uh
employees you are feeling this
particular pinch
locally and let's keep in mind in
1967 at the formation of the New
Hampshire retirement system to combine
all four uh different entities into the
one system the promise was made by the
state of New
Hampshire to uh come into uh that we
will pay
35% so this to me is a very wellth
thought out
bill it doesn't ask for the 35% but asks
a practical amount of 5% to alleviate
the helps to your cities and
towns I think if you went back and I
hope you
did I but if you went back and talked to
your town leaders I think they would
agree to me with me that this is an
unfortunate pinch that has affected now
what gets done that might not be some
sand on the roads or other things when
the municipality such as nashor is
paying $4 million .4
million that wasn't expected 10 years
ago other things have fallen off the
radar to improve the municipality so
this has great impact it has great
impact to your constituents and has
great impact for the cities and towns
that you live in so I cannot support the
itl I think this is kicking would be
kicking the can down the road and not
doing the proper responsibility that we
as legislators should do to look to our
cities towns in the system in this
endeavor thank you madam chair thank you
goie thank you madam chair and I will uh
be voting in opposition to the itl
motion um while 5% is a small amount and
uh not nearly close to the 35% that the
state had uh in years prior uh I think
it's a step in the right direction I
don't believe believe it's up to this
committee to deal with whether it's
affordable or not in the
budget this
committee's dealing with this is whether
or not we feel it's the right thing to
do and if we pass this it will go to
finance and they will determine whether
there is money available or not so for
that reason I think we are going in the
right direction I think it's uh time to
give uh back to our local communities
and I will be voting against the itl
motion thank you
representative
Schulz thank you madam chair um I'm
going to try to not repeat things others
have said I will say this is uh I will
be opposing the itl motion because this
is the issue I hear most about from my
constituents is how high the property
taxes are and this was a promise made to
cities and towns and to have eliminated
it in the first place I think was
uh
abhorent and for all the rhetoric around
taxes we really have let the people of
the Granite State down and the property
tax is too high of a burden for most
people across the state and we need to
5% is really not
enough that's it thank you
representative font
now yes thank you uh Madam chair um I
too must oppose the itl
uh motion uh and based on the um
consequences on property taxes one of
the most uh one of the biggest issues
that I hear from my constituents is uh
affordable housing and in New Hampshire
it is actually considered to be at a
crisis level uh affordable housing we
have an extreme lack of it we have a a
large homeless population that is
struggling and a lot lot of that goes
back to property taxes uh affordable
housing cannot exist with uh the rate of
property tax uh that that we are
leveling so I I have to oppose uh any
legislation that will be passing uh
higher rates back to uh my constituent's
uh property tax rates and I think the
the
5% uh asking the state to to come back
uh and and put in 5% as a minimal uh
minimal amount but it it it at least is
something to uh to help the property tax
payers thank you thank you
representative
Schmid thank you madam chair I too Echo
the sentiments of the uh previous
speakers um we are a policy committee
and and and this committee has an
obligation to stand up for the promise
the commitment that the state made uh
all those years ago which had kept up
until uh the time of the Bill O'Brien
legislature uh when one Party U chose to
uh to zero out the commitment that that
and and the contribution that the state
was making under its obligation under
the
law and has slapped the face of the
taxpayers in every community in this
state and we have an obligation as a
policy committee to step up to state
that we wish to
reinstate uh to the degree possible uh
the uh the contribution that the state
committed to make um if the finance
committee says we can't afford it well
that may be a reality uh but the policy
is Our obligation and it was a shameful
step that the that the legislative
majority back in those days made I know
I voted against it and all my Democrat
colleagues voted against it so it's time
to get off that track and get back on
the right
track I'd like to to make two points one
is that was actually Governor Lynch who
proposed reducing this state
contribution the legislature merely
agreed with him and went even further
than he had
suggested and secondly I'm opposed to it
on the principle that if the state is
paying for part of your
retirement right now the state has no
ability to affect the number of your
employees or how much you pay them
that's your business or your Town's
business if the state is paying a
contribution toward the retirement
system they could very well say you
can't pay a teacher more than x you
can't pay a police chief more than why
and I know that those numbers vary
throughout the state State uh my town
which chooses to pay its policemen not
very much continually loses newly
trained policemen to go to other even
other towns that choose to pay more so
if I'm if I'm contributing to the
pension benefits of your employees who
you choose how many you have and what
you're paying them and you are choosing
to
pay twice three times what our town is
choosing to pay then I should get a say
in how many people you're hiring and
what you're paying them and I think that
that is something that the smaller towns
are more concerned with than the idea
that the state will help to pay for
[Music]
employees well Madam chair if I may
respond uh that is an interesting
argument which is it has an absolute
element of fact in it but I think many
of the cities and towns experience the
pirating if you will of uh employees or
at the very least the luring away of
employees by higher salaries than than
uh than might be the norm but the bottom
line is that the that the state made
that commission commitment uh and it
honored it all those years
representative Schmidt you've said that
please do not repeat yourself
[Music]
representative
Roy um thank you madam chair and I'm I'm
pleased to see um that we're all in
agreement on this bill um having said
that I I actually um I I I am
sympathetic to to the um to the plight
of the cities and towns however I would
echo echo what the chairman said
chairwoman said um with regard to the
state having no control over um what is
going to be done and it's basically
right having a blank check um having
said that if there were some some um
controls in place I might support this
at a future time but of all the times to
be calling in this chit that the the
state uh committed to many many decades
ago uh in the middle of a pandemic is is
not the time to be be calling that in
and to put that extra stress on our
businesses when they're going under um
it is not the right time to do it in in
regard to the tax argument um the tax
rates are set by the towns they decide
who to hire what raises and contracts to
agree to not the state and I would
suggest that the um citizens of the
municipalities look to their towns um to
keep their taxes in check thank
you representative
Vera thank you madam chair we can all be
sympathetic to either side of the issue
unfortunately but my thought is that
it's all one community whether it's
industry that's hurting or whether or
not it's citizens that are hurting it's
we're all the same and two I think it's
it's
uh irrelevant to me whether or not
you're a business that's hurting or
whether or not you're a citizen that's
hurting because
because everyone's looking
for relief of some
contribution thank
you I'll be voting in favor of the Bill
thank you
representative
scitec I'd like to make a couple points
Cent can't hear him can't hear
[Music]
him can you hear me now i' like to make
one of the microphones in the room
rather than trying to use your computer
microphone representative scitec would
thank you I'd like to make a couple
points which are less cogent than what
the chairman has said first we are not
the policy committee on this uh I think
the entire tax structure of New
Hampshire needs to be studied by a
policy committee I'm not satisfied
either with high property taxes but the
Alternatives aren't
attractive uh the so I do not like even
if even if we were the policy committee
I don't like a patchwork approach that
we pulled five 5% out of the air maybe
6% is better 3 and a half% better this
just does not that sort of approach does
not appeal to me I'd really like our tax
structure study the second point is this
the promise was made 50 years ago that's
come
on that's convenient to say but the
Inconvenient Truth is at this time you
communities would pay to get into the
retirement system rather than the other
way around for the benefits that it
affords that it's One-Stop shopping that
it handles all the administrative and
invest and investment features so uh a
50-year-old promise uh I made one to my
wife that's the only one I'm intended to
you representative
Allegro thank you madam chair I'll be
voting in favor of this
itl and I would like to address um a
couple of the arguments that have been
Advanced uh against it first of all this
is a policy question indeed in its very
deepest sense and the question is or the
policy issue is whether or not it's the
responsibility of the municipalities to
administer their own budgets and
maintain something of a balanced account
now the fact that the municipalities
certain municipalities face problem is
an exact example of why they should be
attending to their own budgets and not
relying on the states uh it therefore
should not be the policy of the states
to
uh look in plain English to bail out
municipalities who are not attending to
their budget properly now the other
thing I would like to address and I
think I heard this properly there was a
little uh the audio is not ideal so I'm
not sure uh if I heard properly but I
think I heard one of our colleagues say
that we're all the same uh and therefore
we should all be perhaps in one big pool
of uh slush fund uh but I would uh beg
to disagree that we're all the same some
municipalities manage their budgets
appropriately and some do not um so
having addressed those two I would uh
just like to repeat briefly I'll be
voting in favor of this itl and
encourage the min IP alties to attend to
their budgets
properly representative
fellows thank you madam chair um I will
vote against itl because I know that of
all the state all all the New Hampshire
dollars that are raised to support state
and local government 2third of that is
raised from property taxes and no other
state puts that high a burden on their
property
groda I want to make I want to respond
to my fellow representative made a
comment about my about my response in
that it's not a slush fund this this
this retirement benefit is a attached to
real people who do real work for the
state and the
municipalities and I dare say that many
municipalities are very conscious of
their budget and I think that unless you
have data that shows that there are but
there are irresponsible municipalities I
think that is an affront to the to the
um to the uh towns in New Hampshire who
hard thank you I don't believe anyone
would disagree with that representative
um put myself back in the picture um I
also will be voting against itl and uh I
will take a little of Representative Al
agr's
ation that through all towns and
municipalities in New Hampshire are not
uh exact the same but many by no fault
of their own is my neighboring town of
Allenstown uh do as well as they can to
manage what they have but the fact is
that they are property poor towns so the
income in town via property taxes just
as is not
forward okay there are two people who
wanted to speak in one minute left so I
think that we will reset was just a
question Madam chair please do I just
wanted to know how many people signed in
checking thank you madam chair I didn't
mean to hold up our proceedings but I
helpful what's
that representative O'Brien
uh thank you madam chair I I will try to
be very brief I know the time
constraints uh but when I went to St
peters's grammar school we discussed
ratios and the thing is you got to keep
in mind the statement was made of what
uh municipalities are paying their
employees when you get your retirement
from any nhrs it's figured individually
it's not figured by municipality they
look at how much money you put into the
system and you receive that percentage
now a firefighter in one community may
receive more because he put more money
into the system a firefighter from
another Community will get less because
he was paid less so to say that it is
overburdened is untrue every police
officer and firefighter pays over 12%
into the pension system and that's what
figures it out so therefore it isn't the
issue of what a municipality pays second
I think the statement was made that oh
some of these communities go out and
hire a lot of let's say police officers
or firefighters well I think in the
example of Manchester where they have a
lot of three deckas granted at one given
moment in time there may be too many
firefighters on duty but then when the
building catches fire there is not
enough I as a deputy chief in nashwa
have experienced that and I think by
NFPA rules every Community has the right
to determine what value they put on Fire
Protection in the municipality they so
therefore by NPA national standards it's
not fair for this legislature to take
away that municipality's right to
determine the value that they want to
put on protection of life and property
and their Community I think those
statements weren't completely accurate
so I appreciate Madam speaker uh uh
excuse me Madam chairman for the
opportunity to uh present alternative
thoughts on this thank
you Madame chair I do have the numbers
now I apologize um I didn't count them
exactly but they're close to 50 people
who um signed in and approximately three
were post and one was neutral and that
was Marty Carlin thank you you're
welcome okay is there anyone else who
wishes to
speak uh it's after 11 do we uh yes the
motion is inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 274 the clerk will call the
yes represent
can't
hear
represent he's not on the screen may
have to come back representative scitec
computer microphone is
muted that's right it should be muted
because it will create feedback so he
needs to use one of the microphones in
the
room but I can't hear what he's saying
or who he's calling right we need to
move one of the microphones in the room
moving representative Roy has voted in
the affirmative the clerk affirmative
representative
Pearson representative Pearson hasn't
[Music]
go on have we heard all right no vote
for uh representative
yakovich
yes leus yes representative legro yes
representative Bailey yes repres
representative
again can you hear me yes but you need
to stay right close to the microphone
okay uh I thought I was uh okay
representative Bailey I think was the
last vote and that was yes
no that's what is that again
right representative lonara the motion
is inexpedient to legislate are you
voting yes on the motion or no I thought
I was
was a clear no yeah opposed no sorry I
got about 15 people on Zoom here today
house continue U I don't I don't have a
vote for him at this point he said no he
said
naso point of order Madam
representative
goalie Madam chair point of order do we
have a vote for representative
lonara representative lonara has voted
no okay
Representative no representative show
it
no representative
Judy no representative Schmidt
no representative Schultz no
representative fellows no Representative
funno no representative
Gro no representative
O'Brien no have we heard from
representative
uh the motion eight Ys uh 10 Nays the
motion
fails we will proceed with our regular
452 we'll open the public hearing on
bden uh thank you madam chair can you
guys hear me okay yes great um thank you
madam chair and members of the Edna
committee for the opportunity to
introduce House Bill
452 for the record my name is Andrew
Balden and I represent Manchester Ward
five this bill proposes to prohibit the
secretary of state from running for
state or county office while they are
actively serving as the secretary of
state if they wish to run for another
office they would need to resign prior
to the filing period for the election
that they wish to run
in our current Secretary of State is
proud to tell anyone who will listen
about his role in our government the
secretary of state is a constitutional
officer who serves various functions
spanning both the executive and
legislative branches of
government additionally he is the chief
elections officer in the state this
means that he is ultimately responsible
for the execution of our state elections
for the preparation of all of the
ballots used in those elections for
receiving and verifying all votes cast
and conducting any necessary
recounts this bill seeks to avoid any
scenario where the secretary of state
has the opportunity to put their finger
on the scale if they were to appear on
the ballot as a candidate
themselves consider that the Secretary
of State's signature is printed on every
ballot below the state seal the
secretary of state is the one who
decides how many ballots are delivered
to each polling place they can dictate
the order of party columns on the
ballot imagine someone designing their
own ballots or being in charge of and
having the final say in their own
recount the opportunities to tilt the
scales in their favor are numerous
that's what this bill would address
while much of the rest of the country
has had issues with election security
secretary Gardner will tell you that you
cannot hack a
pencil the Simplicity efficiency and
integrity of our elections are the Envy
of the
country the Integrity of an election is
its most important aspect to ensure
election Integrity we have strict rules
about who has physical access to ballots
for example in times where volunteers
are scarce candidates have stepped up to
work the polls or help process absentee
ballots in fact at my own polling place
in Manchester Ward 5 my wife the other
representative Balden worked the polls
all day because covid caused many of our
usual pole workers to stay home she was
advised that she needed to stay away
from ballots entirely especially marked
ballots and was only assigned tasks
which allowed her to retain a
considerable distance from ballots
she was also not allowed to participate
in any counting activities after the
polls
closed this bill seeks to extend this
Common Sense mindset to our top election
official the Secretary of
State other states have had issues with
individuals using the Secretary of State
position as a stepping stone to the
governorship in Georgia Brian Kemp was
the secretary of state from 2010 to 2018
and retained the position throughout his
candidate receiver governor in the Years
leading up to his gubernatorial run
secretary Kemp closed hundreds of
polling places in disproportionately
minority communities and canceled the
registrations of 1.4 million voters an
act described by the Atlanta Journal
Constitution as the largest mass
disenfranchisement in US
history after winning the 2018 Georgia
election for governor by a narrow margin
of 55,000 votes a tiny fraction of the
number of Voters which he purged in the
Years prior Kemp resigned his position
as Secretary of State and was sworn in
as Governor now can we ever really know
whether Kemp's massive voter Purge
resulted in his victory of course not
but with such a small margin of Victory
I'd say it's reasonable to
wonder the situation in Georgia in 2018
called into question the legitimacy of
its elections and those concerns
certainly carried over into
2020 you see a state's election
Integrity is like a person's
trustworthiness you're either you're
either a trustworthy individual or you
are not just like it's difficult to
establish trust but extremely easy to
lose it it's easy for a state's election
Integrity to become damaged and that
damage can be permanent secretary
Gardner knows this and that's why his
Focus has always been on Election
Integrity in New
Hampshire also consider that our first
the nation status is under attack every
four years if something like what
happened in Georgia were to happen here
well we can kiss our first the nation
status goodbye it would provide critics
of the New Hampshire primary the perfect
argument for why we should no longer be
first New Hampshire hasn't had issues
like these because secretary Gardner who
has served as our secretary of state for
44 years
has never viewed his office as a
stepping stone but we have no way to
know whether our next secretary of state
will be like secretary Garder I also
think it's important to point out that
now is the best time to pass something
like this because we have a long serving
Secretary of State who as far as I can
tell has no interest in running for
governor or any other office and if we
wait for a new individual to take the
office then it would seem like we're
targeting that person and the issue
becomes a lot more political I think we
want to avoid the politicization of the
Secretary of State's office and with
that I conclude my testimony and I'm
committee thank you representative are
committee there being none uh we
appreciate your testimony thank
you I don't see anyone else signed up to
testify on this bill is there anyone out
testify they're seeing I don't see
anyone therefore I'm going to close the
you madam chair will you entertain a
motion for a bill I'm sorry would you
entertain a motion for House Bill
3 I'm so sorry I don't have 377 House
Bill
377 I'm I can't hear you you're you're
you're m not speaking
distinctly would you entertain a motion
for House Bill
377 thank you we are not in executive
session we are scheduled for another
public hearing at this time I'm sorry
thank you right I will recognize you for
you House Bill
456 relative to disclosure of
information from vital
records and you are this because I'm a
co-sponsor
[Music]
yes we are opening a public hearing on
HP
456 I will uh represent excuse me
recognize representative Maguire to
introduce the
Bill thank you this bill is to give the
Department of
Corrections access to information from
vital records that they need in order to
accomplish their
business uh they need to know about
marriages divorces deaths and
births and uh this establishes that they
have an interest in that information and
authorizes the Department of Vital
Records to give it to them and say that
providing this information to the
Department of Corrections does not
violate the privacy of the individuals
involved and there's a representative
from the Department of Correction here
[Music]
details thank you at this time the chair
Rec presents um commissioner Helen Hanks
Corrections good morning honorable
members of the committee my name is
Helen Hanks I'm the commissioner of the
department of Corrections I'm here in
conquered New Hampshire in my office by
myself for the record I thank the
members of the legislature and helping
us sponsor this piece that's brought
before you today uh one area of our
department really less discussed is our
Collections Unit that Collections Unit
um works with about 13,000 individuals
who are in what's called collection only
status and by our fine state laws that
group has to collect fines fees and
restitution owed to victims and
survivors of crime so when individuals
uh you know finish they their supervised
sentence they can then be put on
collection only uh in testimony that I
did email it shows you that we have that
13,000 individuals it is one area that
in my time as commissioner I found that
we do not have a sufficient data set to
understand and to do an effective job
when people get married change their
name and the key part is again these
people are not under our supervision so
you might intuitively say well don't you
know where they live well we knew where
they last lived and if they move or get
married or for that matter if they die
we don't have a consistent data set and
so in reviewing our statutes I found uh
this section of law that allows uh an
potential for a memorandum of
understanding between the Secretary of
State's office we are asking just for a
data Limited set for people who are
under collection only we want to make
that clear we don't need information
about anybody else but just to really
work to have clean data the opportunity
again to collect that ongoing
restitution for individuals who are
affected by crime in New Hampshire um we
collected last year just over $2
million at this point we've collected
about $1.4 million in state fiscal year
2021 um I did include in the testimony
that'll be shared with you that section
of Statute that requires us to do this
and certainly Avail myself for any
committee thank you are there any
thanks there seeing none thank you
commissioner thank you everyone be well
you as well
Mr scandin was there and now he's
disappeared Mr chairman can you hear me
oh there you are yes thank you go ahead
yeah I uh you called on me I think I got
kicked off and then rejoined but uh
anyway uh thank you Mr chair uh members
of the committee I'm David scanlin
deputy secretary of state um just would
like to inform the committee that the
division of Vital Records is a division
uh under the Secretary of State uh we're
charged with the collection of uh
collecting Vital Records um under RSA
5-c uh we are uh given the
responsibility of making sure that the
data that we collect is private and
confidential uh we share the entire data
set with the Department of Health and
Human Services
uh so that they can use it for research
um following Health Trends you know
certainly the information that's
collected uh in Vital Records is
important to tracking the the pandemic
that we're currently going
through um there is also limited use to
the New Hampshire retirement system so
that they can locate uh Heirs of uh of
uh members of the state retirement
system to make sure that uh you know
they can uh you know receive proceeds
from a retiree if there are any left
over in terms of what the Department of
Corrections is asking this is probably
the first time that there has been a
request of data from Vital Records so
that uh
uh fees uh and collections can be made
of individuals in the state so I will
leave it up to the committee to
determine whether that's good policy or
not but if you choose to do that uh I
would suggest that on page one of the
bill line
11 which is under the the RSA 5c where
it says the Department of Corrections
shall have access
to uh I would recommend adding in a
limited set of and then continue vital
records information in accordance with
the provisions of RSA 21-h
colon
8 common Roman numeral
11-c which is the Department of
Correction statute um that's just to
make it clear in both sets that in in
both uh statutes relating to vital
records and Corrections that what's
being requested is a limited set of
information
uh limited to the uh information that
would be necessary for corrections to
fulfill the the function that uh uh
corresponds with the policy that you
determine uh is beneficial to the state
and with that I would be happy to answer
any
questions thank you Mr secretary does
anyone have any
questions I
Schmidt thank you Mr
[Music]
uh
je um the commissioner of Corrections uh
this question um but you have addressed
it uh in a very tactful and uh and an
illustrative manner um and
so I I serve on the vital records
privacy board as you know um and um we
are very scrupulous in
our in our monitoring of requests for
data uh that the state gathers and and
and and
maintains um for necessary needs and
also uh for providing opportunities to
study for statistical purposes um but
this is a similar type of situation in a
way uh and I'm wondering whether you
have any reservations about uh uh the
misuse Mr chair I I don't know if that
question was directed at me I had a
little it was it was directed at you
David okay uh thank you
representative Schmidt I uh you know I I
I know the the operational Corrections
is topnotch and and I am not concerned
about misuse of information and you know
we would certainly tie down the details
of that in the memorandum of
understanding uh just as we have done
with the Department of Health and Human
Services um the the the only issue that
I have is you know again a matter of
policy and that is should this data be
used uh to collect from uh citizens of
the State of New Hampshire and you know
right now that my understanding is that
all of the data that we have is uh in
that division is limited to
research um whether it's uh you know
medical research or Academia um none of
the information that I'm aware of in
there is used to go after citizens uh to
collect payments that may be do the
state of New Hampshire so um as I
understand this request that would be a
fairly fundamental change in how that
data is used followup Madam chair go
ahead
Mr chairman sorry um uh so um is there
we I think we all recognize that there
is a need uh for uh some state agency to
be able to Monitor and
administer uh the uh the obtaining of
data uh for the purpose of uh making
restitution as this bill uh clearly uh
targets uh is there any other way of
knowledge that's
reasonable represent I I'm not aware of
any right right okay well thank you very
much are there any further questions Mr
scand I see none thank you Mr secretary
here your
testimony is there anyone else wishing
spell Mr chairman seeing that there's no
one else that I'm blocking from having
an opportunity to ask a question I do
have another question of deputy
secretary scanland if I
might umiss scan go ahead deputy
secretary scan thank thank you very much
so uh Deputy scanland is it possible uh
that you're aware of uh such um
modalities in in any other state that is
where it's been or would be uh you know
here yes representative Schmidt I do not
know the answer to your question New
Hampshire is unique in that in most
other states the division of final
records falls under the Department of
Health and Human Services um if if it's
the committee's desire we can uh we can
send out a questionnaire just to see if
other states use this
information uh in the manner that's
requested under this house
bill well I would certainly want the
committee to weigh in on it before we
would request the the your department to
do
that thank
you okay thank you again Mr scanon um
there being no other questions and no
one else wishing to testify I'm going to
declare this heing
okay we will recess and resume at 1:15
[Music]
representative fellows did you say
something yeah I yes can um I have an
amendment
for I don't know the number the mushroom
bill which I fig we're not going to do
today but I just don't know how to
distribute it am I supposed to email
that to everybody or do I mail it to you
well I um you can email it to Pam oriam
and ask for distribution Miriam okay
thank
you Miriam's the better one yes Miriam
it's
e
is there anybody out there in Zoom
land we're
here how's this how I'm trying to get
this we having some technical problems
today um how is this microphone sounding
it's it's sounding good it's certainly
loud you know I mean or or certainly
strong enough you know you
could Taun it down a tiny bit I'm not
I'm trying to not turn it up to 11 here
you know right that's smart so I'm
trying to figure out a way to adjust the
inputs that that sounds good I think
it's you know as long as you're keeping
a moderate um volume personally I think
that's perfect
and uh people here I know I tend to yell
at my computer
myself well I mean those that know me
fully understand that I I'm not a
moderate volume person
right oh that sounds perfect right now
just as you you know your last sentence
there that was clear but not too loud
okay I yell at my computer all the time
room can you hear us yes okay thank you
and M would be okay if I put this to the
speaker view so
115 okay it's 1:15 and I'm going to open
the public hearing on HB 72 and
recognize representative McGuire to
introduce the
bill good afternoon Mr chair m committee
I'm Carol Maguire from Mar District 29
which is the towns of Allenstown epon
and Pittsfield and House Bill
72 is a bill that failed last year in
the Senate after passing the house it
adopts amendments to the state building
code and the state fire code that have
been approved by the relevant technical
boards that is the building code review
board and the
uh State Board of Fire Control list list
them
and these are
all useful amendments many of them are
to simplify building requirements and
make it easier to build housing um the
board of Fire Control approved four
additional amendments after this bill
went to press that is in their December
meeting and and I would like to bring an
amendment to include those in the
bill I have them with me if anyone wants
to read them I can send you the text if
you are interested in the details of
those building build of their fire code
amendments I will answer what questions
I does anyone have any questions repr
can we get uh representative lanzera
back into a
it okay I'll take
care um okay there oh representative BR
yeah I'm sorry um thank you um Mr chair
representative aguire what was the
reasoning for this bill not passing the
Senate last year it was combined into an
omnus bill that was
V thank
representative there seeing none is
there anyone else who would like to
bill if if it would be possible for um
repres representative Roy and um
chairman Maguire to speak a little bit
louder I would
appreciate yeah we're we're sharing a
microphone that we're passing back and
forth but we'll try try and keep that in
mind um okay so I'm going to go ahead
and close the public Hearing in that
bill and we will be opening the next
137 we just referring to I thought we
were going to resume at 115 which is
what it is I yeah it's 145 stand
by next one's what 13 145 yeah so you
can get back here yeah
okay um I I would just like to say that
I have an atomic clock you know the one
that gets the time from the satellite
and um frequently our hearings are
opening 2 minutes early compared to that
clock and also compared to the time I
see on my
computer this thing's a little
fast okay I didn't hear what was going
114 we open light that takes care of
that
representing McGuire were they veto
or that was V because others were just
left
I we're well we're representative scitec
just asked me if this Bill had been
tabled in the senate or vetoed and I was
assuring him that it had in fact been
combined in an Omnibus it was vetoed and
the veto was not
overr and I was representative MC
Williams who was a co-sponsor
uh spoke at the house session that we
needed to pass the Omnibus because this
particular bill was um representative
Maguire when you review the minutes I
have said they've all been T you may
want to change this one is not okay well
I'd like to go into executive session
and move ought to pass on House Bill
number
21116 which is brought To Us by
representative
of
591 05 no the amendment number is 0116
[Music]
H Madame chair representative O'Brien
may I question the chair sure uh I was
inquiring as to the procedure that the
chair wants to follow it seems that we
had opened up an executive session on
274 uh it was voted and therefore uh
another alternative motion is uh
eligible to be made and should we not
representative representative o'ri I'll
yield yes Madam chair I know that know
that is true and I am choosing to deal
with House Bill 591 first all right
chair Madam chair what was the amendment
Amendment which I sent out again after
we uh after the
hearing yes I I do have it I just wanted
to be sure I was uh looking at the right
one the the reason I'm proposing the
abrami amendment is that it pro it fixes
a problem with the bill as written where
tobacco um where establishments with
both tobacco and alcohol licenses were
getting charged
double what it what the amendment does
it establishes a gradated tobacco only
license at the same price as a alcohol
license that is so much for one register
so much for three four registers that
sort of thing uh so that the
the fees are parallel to those for
alcohol because and that that's um seems
appropriate
uh it leaves in
the
um investigators check confirm
that uh it has examiners rather than
investigators which are l less
expensive and while I'm not entirely
sure they need them I'm willing to pass
it over
to pass this amendment and let Ways and
Means deal with it because we're
not I didn't understand why they were
they wanted more investigators or
inspectors
and so it's
representative Roy you wish to speak on
your second no I would just endorse what
you said does anyone else wish to speak
there's a hand that that is
representative Shu representative
Shu thank you yes um I'm in agreement
with
the person that deals with fees but I am
not in agreement with the portion of the
amendment changes those titles from
investigators to
examiners um we heard from
testimony during the hearing that um
number one The Examiner position does
not have the same Authority if they find
uh inequities um problems when they're
doing an
examination they don't the immediate
right to take action that an
investigator would would and there was
expressed a fear that evidence could be
lost between the time of an examination
and investigator coming to the scene uh
that's a major concern to me I think um
obviously if that kind of thing happens
we're losing Revenue um that's the
likely
outcome um and so if there was a chance
that the amendment could be redrafted so
that would cover the fees but not change
those titles I would be in
favor I went with the
investigators because I believe
that from what I heard at the hearing
the exam the investigators are necessary
if there is an issue of criminal
Behavior
the
um the examiners are for financial
misconduct or or errors or omissions and
in my experience uh errors and omissions
and financial
uh poor recordkeeping is much more
likely than criminal Behavior but you're
entitled to your your position on this I
yes uh if I may speak representative
O'Brian uh I too have some concerns with
this I think if we look at what
determines a sworn officer uh and
basically I think the liquor
commissioner offices do have full power
and authority as Swan officers within
the state in the Hamshire the other
thing to consider here is also I think
if I have it right which is Linda's law
in other words a sworn officer cannot be
a false testimony in court to any type
of infraction and if that does occur
then that officer jeopardizes his career
and on top of it jeopardizes his
credibility when you have officers such
as this who are not completely sworn
offices it could cause some I think
future problems that the testimony given
by these particular people are they held
to the same standards as we are as a
state are holding the swan officers
speak are you saying something no
no the uh in that case the motion is to
pass the abrami
amendment
01168 and the clerk will
the representative Roy yes clerkes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative
yakovich yes representative leus yes
representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey yes representative
naso Santo Nas yes yes representative
goalie no Representative
sht no representative
Judy
no representative Schmidt no
are you did I hear you I don't
know okay I hear you now representative
fellows no representative
fno unfortunately no uh representative
groda sadly no representative O'Brien no
and the
that was the
amendment I'm sorry I couldn't hear that
did the amendment carry or no the
amendment passed 10 to n thank you
representative lak do you have a further
Amendment you bring forward uh yes I'd
like to move uh ought to pass on
uh the amendment 2021
180h this is a another amendment on this
Bill yes you can only have one Amendment
on a bill when we send it to the clerk
if we pass both amendments they will be
combined into one of okay all right
they're they're not incompatible okay
and that number is you need a second
it's
180 number
us I didn't hear who the second was on
please
and excuse me excuse me Madame
chair that
Judy can I have the number of the Second
Amendment please the number of the
Second Amendment is
0180 it's the one that I brought to the
hearing okay eliminates the positions
entirely okay but um I'm sorry this is
the first time I see two
amendments and on one
bill I don't know if I'm mistaken or
what yes it doesn't happen very often
but we C but if the amendments are
compatible we can apply two of them and
they will be combined by OS into the
final committee
chair person leus do you wish to speak
to your
Amendment uh I do um basically it's it's
not clear there's really a need for uh
any additional staff for this I mean
there already there's already licensing
and staff to enforce that for both
alcohol and
tobacco and at least from what I heard
from the uh the hearing it didn't seem
like there'd be a great deal more work
bill Madame speak Madam uh chairman can
I can I ask a a a clarifying question
yes Pam I'm looking at the amendment
that you um just adopted and it has a SE
two sections that deal with funding um
with with the positions sections 11 and
and the the amendment that you're
discussing right now says that
everything after section 11 shall be
replaced with just the um effective date
right so it repeals the sections 11 and
12 it only repeals section
11 you're so right that was foolish of
me I think I think the Amendment added
some some a new section and changed the
numbering and and so I I think it's you
know you can fix it but I'm not positive
it's clear with this amendment all right
days no the difference is that the
amendment says repeal section after
section 11 which in the original bill
was the positions in the funding for if
in the bill as amended it's only the
funding I don't have it in front of me
but I thought 11 changed also 60
days 11 it's this second Amendment only
deals with sections after 11 could this
be a technical cleanup that that all us
would do when combining them is that
legitimate or uh I think we're getting
to the point where it's it's not
legitimate so I I think we're going to
have to vote down this
Amendment
sorry madam chair can't the amendment
just be
withdrawn it could that would save us
the
bother all right I I'll withdraw my
motion fine we will withdraw the
so representative Shu if you wish I I
think we should should stop now we're
we're feeding ourselves over the head
representative shuid if you wish to
redraft the amendment to call for the
investigators rather than the
examiners uh we can discuss that when we
get back on this I don't think we can
finish this
today all right so we we've passed an
amendment and it's just hanging there
right I think we're I think we're just
kind of hanging at this
point the status is we're going to
recess with the amendment passed correct
okay to confirm we're recessing this
executive session after passing that the
do we have do we have a couple
minutes yeah
[Music]
the amendment is passed and my
discussion should have been at that time
I'm not sure it should have been I
didn't want to make a discussion but
it's disappointing to me because I want
very much to work with people on this
this is not this does not reflect how
the real world works there's not going
to be a loss of evidence nobody gets
arrested on the spot you know need a
sworn officer go to an IRS audit and if
they invest find criminal activity the
guy doesn't lock you up then that's just
not
realistic uh I don't understand the
motivation why it has to be in well I do
understand a motivation why it might be
investigators rather than examiners and
I'm I'm
unhappy
that that be has become a sticking point
more Madam
chair
recess
ex Madam chair
yes I I would just want to respond to my
honorable friend from Salem that that
was part of the testimony we did hear
that evidence would be lost I asked
specifically on a question and the
difference between examiners and ex uh
investigators and that was a testimony
from from the Department that evidence
could be lost so I just want to remind
testimony thank you thank
you later wor I think that was indicated
as a possible worst case scenario but it
we've got what about 10 minutes or
something yeah I wouldn't mind if
somebody
um
next
[Music]
person
Madam chair what's our current stat
St our current status is that the next
hearing starts at 1:45 and we have two
minutes do you mind if I straighten that
clock out please do okay I'll do not
if I can reach it um I cannot give you
assistance of looking at the chairs
s
Madam chair I don't know this is a
technical issue or if folks have changed
computers I'm seeing uh reprentative
Roy's name label on I believe it's
representative lakas I'm uh I'm sitting
in uh to chair because uh
okay Maguire it's her bill and
representative Roy had to go speak in
another
committee so I'm the
virtual I'm the virtual I thought maybe
I thought maybe he had grown facial hair
quickly
no it turns out that all that I'm a
sponsor or co-sponsor of all the bills
this afternoon so
I'm representative sh he'd have to be a
that's true we we do have a different
especially I can put his hat on and
things I
just for planning purposes what's the
Bill what was
that
137 yeah 137
yeah start in just a moment I'm waiting
is it
is okay I'm opening the uh public
hearing on House Bill
137 and I'm recognizing um
Bill thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee I'm Carol Maguire
representing marac 29 which is
Allenstown Epsom and Pittsfield and
House Bill one 37 exempts from the
normal rulle making
process standards and protocols for
information technology telephones and
cyber
security this is not because these
things don't need to be approved it's
because putting them in the proper
format for rulle making would make them
totally unintelligible to the regulated
Community which is against the the point
of Ru making uh these these protocols
and standards are
um developed by the department of
Information
Technology the state the information
technology which consists of most of the
other agencies that use
technology uh work on them um and
approved by them not approved they are
consult with them so that these
standards are
in an understand and appropriate
[Music]
can does anyone have any questions yes I
have a question uh proceed thank you so
much um representative Maguire can you
please give me an example of I think I
know what you're trying to say but I'm
having a hard time um you know using an
example can you give us an example of
what
rule the um would be involved and how it
would be difficult to put it in rule
making is that is my
question sort of I I it's how it would
be difficult to understand the correct
the thing is that our Ru making format
is prescribed by the manual and it's got
a very explicit format on how rules are
to be laid out and it's developed by
lawyers
the people who use these uh standards
and Protocols are primarily engineers
and it's very difficult to find somebody
who who speaks both
languages
uh also it's not clear that the cyber
be
openly uh open to the world as they
would be if they went through Ru Mak
I think that there's some privacy
concerns
there followup
please follow up thank you Mr chair um
so you're saying that if they were in
rule if the rules were
published which in rule making the rules
are published and open to the public
there would be security issues with the
information in the rule make in the
rules it's very possible that the
security uh rules would have information
we don't want to publish that is how we
detect uh false um false identifications
[Music]
attacks actually I have a a question if
these aren't going to be published then
how are the people they might apply to
going to be aware of them I'm a little
confused
they can be published to the agencies
without necessarily putting them on the
State website for anyone interested to
to
review I have oh sorry go ahead uh any
other questions did you have one I do
have another question but I'll yield to
someone is someone else has a question
um I guess the director of it is uh
present wants to speak I I have my hand
up oh
sorry so okay proceed so um
representative Maguire um having a
little bit of background in it I I
believe that um a lot of these standards
are probably industry standards do you
think that that's proba
true
[Music]
yes what Dennis gay
gay um Dennis gay uh is
recognized thank you Mr chair and thank
you representative Maguire for
introducing this bill um my name is
Dennis goule I am the uh the
commissioner for the Department of
Information Technology
and um I asked for this um language for
a couple reasons
um first of all a couple of years ago U
LBA audit report um had recognized had a
finding where they saw there was a a
disconnect between the fact that part of
Statute said I should be making rules
and another part um I didn't have
actually have any rule making Authority
so they said we need to fix this this
inconsistency
in in statute so we actually had this uh
this bill up last time but it didn't
pass I think it got lumped into a larger
Bill and that didn't pass so we're we're
trying to to do this again to mainly
because I want to get you know I want to
chip away at all of those uh LBA audit
findings and this is one of them um so
why does this make sense um in in the
case of
doit we have a a a a body in statute
called the it Council and the IT Council
uh
develops um it
policy um including cyber security
policy and then that policy has the has
the fourth force of law through RSA
21r um so the part of this language U
removes references to rul making
Authority um and the other part of it
makes consistent how we govern Telecom
um back in
2016 the Telecom part of of the state
business which is about 8% of my budget
right now was moved from Department of
Safety over into the department of
Information Technology and they were
under manual procedures so um so what
this does is it cleans up a number of
things it takes away the reference to
rulemaking
Authority um and it and it puts the
Telecom Group which is now part of a DE
it under the same governance
methodology as the rest of it which is
the information Technology
Council uh that concludes my formal
testimony I'm happy to answer any
questions guess I'll ask a qu I guess
I'll ask a question Mr chairman if I
may commissioner commissioner
um there are some situations as you know
I I been on the Jael car now for 15
years uh and I know that there are some
agencies where uh the rules are exempt
from
541a um review by the Jael car um such
as the uh
Dr uh because many of their rules uh
have to be adopted in response to
Federal rule changes uh which have to be
responded to very fast if not
immediately um and the Jael car process
just can't can't do it that fast so Dr
is largely exempt from uh from
541a review um but there are some others
like the commit the Department of
Corrections where they have certain
rules uh that they really can't reveal
because they their their clientele if
you who are locked up uh and to the
degree that they that all the rules are
public uh it it creates security pro
breaches or possibilities of breaches um
so I'm a little bit wondering whether
this is somewhat similar with uh with
doit where we also have not not we we
have potential criminals for sure the
hackers who are constantly bombarding us
and I'm Wonder whe wondering whether
that's the reason that some of this
stuff is uh is not coming up before our
our panel for review or whether it's
just
a different situation
entirely well the the um the
inconsistency sir existed um because I
uh doy actually never had rule making
Authority but there was reference to
rule making in 541a which we we are
asking to be removed in terms of the the
ability to not publish information
that of a of a sense sort like cyber
security related stuff um there was
actually a change to right to know um in
it was done in association with the some
uh Department of Education um
legislation I think two sessions ago um
where the the entities were concerned
about having to reveal the results of a
cyber um risk assessment to the public
because of course I the results of a
risk assessment will often have findings
that point to weaknesses so um we worked
with um Department Ed and some other
folks and put language in um right to
know law that exempts sensitive cyber
security information from from um right
to
know so we're we're so so in terms of
having um you know um transparency on
our governance um the the um the it
council meeting is a public meeting um
there right now they're um two state
representatives on that on that body um
I haven't seen who's been appointed in
this
session but last session it was rep
Representatives over in eel uh addition
addition to it being a public meeting we
do publish all the the results and and
um information on our websites so it's
all there for to be completely
transparent with one exception um we
will in some cases we've done it I think
twice in the um five and a half years
I've been commissioner that we went into
a non-public session with just the
council a non- meeting to discuss uh
sensitive cyber security information so
that was not actually
published I hope that answers the
question that that helps me thank you
Mr I see none thank you very
all would anyone else like to testify on
this
bill seeing none I will close the public
hearing
I would
move
137 is there a
second I'm sorry could could we please
was that house bill
137 yes one we just had the hearing on
okay that's fine I just didn't quite
catch all the numbers thank you if
you're looking for a second I'll second
that represent pear than you pe McGuire
Pearson y we're in executive
[Music]
motion uh yes this is a simple and
helpful bill for the Department of
Information Technology and I think we
it uh representative Pearson would you
like to speak to your second yeah I
think the uh the commissioner brought up
some very important points
and
um and I really couldn't top what Carol
just did so yeah let's let's do
it all right would anyone else like to
speak on I uh representative lakus yeah
and this may have been covered by the
commissioner but I could not understand
everything you said and that's so I just
had I was little surprised I wasn't
familiar with having rules that were not
public or weren't handled by uh jail
cars is there and he may have talked
about this but is there any uh
legislative review of the rules uh
created in this
[Music]
way no there are a number of things that
are not considered rules the Department
of Transportation has their Highway
structural standards the standards for
signs and the rules for driveways on
state roads for example do not go
through making
um legislative oversight
minimal anyone else wishing to
discussion seeing none the clerk will
RO Purp representative
Maguire
yes uh the clerk votes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative
yakovich representative
yakovich
yes uh representative leus yes
representative algro yes
representative Bailey yes representative
lenara yes repres reprentative Sant
naso yes representative goalie yes
representative
Judy sounded like yes didn't it
representative Schmidt
yes representative
Schultz
yes I could hear a squeak do was that a
yes would squeak again please sure yes
yes okay representative fellows
yes uh representative fno yes
representative cro yes representative of
Brian yes and the chair in this case
representative Roy chair holds yes okay
it's uh 19
is Mr chair would you entertain a motion
on House Bill 377 relative to the
authority of the Fire Marshall to Grant
exemptions from high fire code
houses 10 minutes do you think we
complete it in that time
oh I'm not seeing not hearing you very
well
Madam I missed that I couldn't hear you
very
well say we we're not hearing you very
well okay fine uh what is your motion
representative Gordon how to pass on
second who's second please second
represent goalie represent go goalie
okay uh representative grer would you
like to speak to your motion I would
love to thank you very much um I think
the house bill 377 is a wise way of um
handling recovery houses in New
Hampshire in that it allows some
recovery houses exemptions but at least
gives everyone a minimum and uh minimum
uh level of of required safety for those
buildings where
people are recovering from various forms
of abuse um I think that um this is
uh that's that's it that's all I need to
say thank you and represent goie would
you like to speak to you a
second thank you Mr chair and I'll just
be brief I think we uh heard during the
testimony that this is granting
exemptions to the fire code and uh not
putting any hardships on folks as the
exemptions as such things as
sprinklers um and I I seeing what's
going on around Manchester and I'm sure
it's happening in other communities this
is a much needed piece of legislation
and uh I will be supporting
it thank you would anyone else like to
speak yes uh representative scite I just
want to comment I never did understand
despite trying very hard Kim Bach's
objections to this bill I didn't see
that she was affected by it but okay uh
the Bill's
fine I agree with you represent
scitech any further
discussion I think it's important that
we we're on the record here in a way
that we uh have not been
previously um and I think it's important
to address this issue that Miss Bach uh
raised with us uh uh because uh I too
struggled to see how uh their concerns
uh were being stepped on by uh this bill
or the Fire Marshal's uh
projected treatment of the of the
subject I think it's important for for
for me for me to say that um I I I I
don't want to step on that agency's uh
you know concerns but I I don't see them
and and we want to be on the record as
saying we don't think that's where the
Fire Marshal's
going exactly thank you representative
representative
Pearson thank you Mr chair um I actually
sat on the subcommittee for this bill I
was I was part of the bill that or the
committee that worked on this
over uh the
summer and I would agree with some of
the other statements that were made here
in the sense that yeah yeah Kim block
did not make a valid argument and and
sadly enough during the subcommittee
work uh New Hampshire core was a little
contradictory because they seemed to
want to use the law in certain ways when
it benefited them and then would flip to
a different part of the law to try to
make an argument when it didn't work for
them uh we heard testimony from folks
that had actually gone through the
recovery houses and the concerns that
they they had and you know one of one of
the things that was brought up that was
telling was the idea that you know when
you're when you're in this situation you
have surrendered yourself in a way I
mean if you're you know when you're
trying to to deal with your addiction
you you've put yourself into a recovery
house you have given it you've given it
up to to this process and when someone
is in a situation where they are truly
kind of at their lowest
they do truly rely on the people
recovering these houses or excuse me
that are managing these these recovery
houses for their safety and you know the
testimony that we heard from from folks
during this process really did um shed
some concerns that exist and uh I think
that that's something that you know let
let's not get lost here we you know we
really truly want these people to be
successful and we want to create an
environment to which they will be
successful but they have to feel that
they're safe
and you know the I don't think it's the
I don't think the legislature needs to
surrender that to a a regulatory agency
that frankly regulates
itself so um you know I'm gonna be
supporting this bill certainly uh thank
you we're on a time crunch here we want
to get the vote gotta does anyone else
um seeing No Hands raised the clerk will
call the
role representative uh representative
McGuire
yes clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative
yakovich yes representative leus yes
representative algro yes representative
Bailey yes representative
s representative goalie yes
representative sh yes representative
Judy we representative Schmidt yes
representative
Schultz
yes I guess that's yes representative
fellows yes representative funno yes
representative groa yes representative
O'Brien yes and the chair the chair
votes yes
no thank you just wanted to test my
microphone again can you hear me okay
now no Charlie Brown's teacher going on
is it too
loud sounds good now yeah that's good
okay thank you sorry okay um at this
time I'd like to open the public NOP
actually I've got four minutes left
I didn't have to read it that fast then
no we we all spoke and read very fast
good have a moment I'd like
[Music]
to comment that it seemed to me that the
objections to
377 were looking at the requirements for
single family homes when they should
have been looking at the requirements
for boarding houses or such like and so
they were comparing apples and oranges
when they're saying it's
discriminatory
okay uh Madam chair may I ask a question
sure uh Madame chair when do you
consider uh bringing up two uh
274 again uh I would hope that it would
be today because uh a very good debate
was held everybody did get to speak to
the particular point of views and it is
fresh right now in everybody's mind so
while it is still right on the front
burner I would recommend that today
would be the proper time to to discuss
session at this time I'd like to open a
hearing on HB
357 and introduce uh have representative
guire introduce the bill oh excuse me
represent Spain is with us oh
representative Spain is here with
US Representative Spain you
recognized has he not been admitted
am I on you are oh great thank you
members of the committee and and Mr
chair um and Madame chair sitting in the
background
um I bring this bill forward today uh as
an attempt to take and and put a better
handle on our current process for uh
ensuring that that
rules that we have made through
administrative process are um not
allowed to expire without being
updated and that they are uh updated in
a timely fashion I attended a uh
political uh
convention last term the beginning of
last term so it's three years ago now uh
but this is the first opportunity I've
had to to bring something forward
because uh it came came to light during
that uh when I got to see some software
that was being worked on by a uh a
startup group that actually was being
sold in multiple states that managed
their administrative rules and it would
give the Departments a warning that a
certain rule that they had put in place
was about to expire um it would
recommend on rules that hadn't been used
uh or hadn't been updated that they be
um allow to expire and removed from the
books and it would give everybody a
better idea that uh what rules had
expired that we shouldn't be trying to
enforce because uh that just causes
problems for the state when you you try
to enforce a rule that has been expired
and is is technically not valid anymore
and I had a lot of discussions including
some discussions with representative
Maguire um and um I feel that the study
committee would give us the best ability
to take a look at the options available
I know that the governor's office was
looking at this software package and it
is something that the state may decide
to invest in in order to have a handle
Statewide on all of our administrative
rules when they expire which ones are
being used and such um but it more so
the the study committee could just
double check to ensure that our process
is as streamlined as possible to ensure
that we are not um allowing expired
rules to stay on the books and that
we're not um forgetting to remind
departments when they have to update
their rule because it is about to expire
and that's about it it's just a simple
study committee um so uh I'd appreciate
the committee looking at this and um I
would appreciate an OTP so we could move
forward with with trying to get a handle
on on what's happening with the
administrative rules across the state um
New Hampshire did list among the top for
having a sheer volume of administration
rules and uh there were quite a lot when
they ran a demo for the state that that
were already expired um and I had no
idea that we had so many expired rules
still on the books so um that's all I've
got I'll take questions if anybody's got
any thank you uh representative Schultz
thank you for taking my question can you
hear me okay I can good because my mic
wasn't working earlier I'm just curious
what convention this was if you don't
mind my asking
uh it was the American legislative
exchange
Council thank
you any more questions for
representative Spain uh representative
gr thank you I guess I have a question
to the chair and to um other members of
the
committee regarding a study committee
no the speaker has said that we will not
pass any study committee bills the
options are since administrative rules
is fully within our scope of action is
to study it ourselves without a formal
study committee we've done that on a
number of
issues and to do that we can either
retain the bill or kill
it and I would like to like to mention
that expired administrative rules cannot
be enforced
that's one of the few clear improvements
we've made in our rul making process in
the last few
years thank you I have no questions for
um representative Spain I was just
concerned when I saw study committee
thank
you thank you representative any uh
fellows thank you um I would just like
to ask um which agencies you you
um cons consulted before you put this
bill together to find out what they told
you were the reasons that there might be
expired um
laws that have not been renewed yet uh
particularly in this particular year I
can see there are reasons why that would
happen uh thank you for your question it
was actually um over two years ago when
I spoke
with the governor's office and
um one of the executive counselors it
Escapes Me Now who it was um but uh they
were investigating the same software
company so I had a discussion with the
governor's office and they said yes they
had also been made aware that there
there were rules in some of the agencies
that had not been renewed within the
time frame that they were supposed to be
renewed and so technically they were
expired and no had tried to enforce them
so that they really should be cleaned up
and removed um rather than just sitting
around as expired rules and and that's
my intent on this is to try to just
ensure that if we have expired rules
hanging around we we remove them and if
we have rules that expired inadvertently
we remember to renew
them follow up yes please um I'm I'm
just thinking um what I know about the
process that's involved to get rules
changed you know it involves public
hearings and all that sort of thing um
that and I was at I worked at the
Department of Education and I did not
work specifically with rules but I would
hear about you know some of the things
that were going on that um it can it can
take a considerable amount of time when
you hear in in public hearings that
people have different ideas of how a
rule should be changed and that that
could be one of the reasons that um they
may may expire are are you familiar with
situations like
that uh thank you for that question um I
I'm not aware that the majority of the
rules that went and sat on that sat as
expired rules came about because they
couldn't determine a way to renew them
based on public hearing or public
sentiment uh I I was um essentially told
by
those that I talked to that there are
instances when the the department
forgets that a rule is there we don't
have a reminding mechanism that says hey
this rule is uh you know 10 years old
and it needs to be renewed um and the uh
the software that we were looking at did
that it would come up and say hey this
needs to be renewed this year it's it's
hit its time frame for your State's
guidelines on when rules need to be
renewed I am aware that there's a lot of
problem with with getting all of the
public opinion I think that's one reason
why New Hampshire has chosen to have the
rules last a longer period of time than
some other states uh there are other
states where the rules expire every year
annually or rules expire every two years
um ours tend to last a lot longer uh
because we we have such a large number
of them and it's hard to get public
input and sentiment on all the rules and
ensure that they are are going forward
in the right way um part of this whole
studied thank you any further questions
spy there see I see none so thank you
representative spine thank
you is there anyone else wishing to
[Music]
yes I'm Carol McGuire representing marac
District
29 my concern is that
the rules that tend to expire without
anyone noticing are frequently from the
smaller agencies that don't have very
many rules so they don't have to deal
with it very often and so they just
forget about it until until somebody
points out that their rule has been
expired for a year HHS for example we
were talking about the child care rules
those are being held up because they're
debating how to solve what the
requirement should be we were talking
about that on I think it was House Bill
230 but um
it's I think that some of the issues of
rules being overlooked will be helped by
the oplc because they've got a central
rule writing Authority that the many of
the boards didn't really have before
they were
Consolidated in any event I I
co-sponsored this I thought it would be
a useful idea but in this year I think
that we can't pass it and our choice is
to retain it if we want to work on it or
[Music]
you thank you representative mgu any
bill there seeing none I will close the
public hearing on HB
[Music]
357 question of the
chair uh yes go ahead represent are we
intending to uh exec the uh the bill we
heard this morning on uh on the drones
to put it in the usual
language authorizing an additional
member of the that uh that board
Aviation users Advisory
Board House Bill
298 298 is the correct number I believe
right I think I would second if you made
a motion Mr represent
Schmid well I I want I don't I don't
want to manage the committee that's the
chair's job but uh but I I think that
was a bill that seemed to have be
unobjectionable and I'd just like to see
us get rid of it i' get it get it passed
that get rid of okay in that case
representative Schmidt if we can
restrain ourselves we have seven minutes
before the next hearing and
representative Gera has a motion on
House Bill
298 I to pass on House Bill
298 I will second that motion
representative
Pearson do you do you wish to consider
oh
shoot Now's the Time y y we should yep
yes so I should I we should vote on the
amendment
moment does anybody have an amendment
number
206h okay so I'm move a to pass
on on
Amendment house I'm sorry what was that
H do you wish to speak to the to your
fora this is a bill that um this the
amendment uh
no do I have to speak to the to the uh
I'm a little bit discombobulated that
Amendment comment threw me off I'm
sorry can I yield to representative
Pearson if you don't have anything to
say you can just say no I think it's
self-explanatory it is self-explanatory
thank you concur with that yes any
anytime anytime during the process we
discover something that needs to be
tweak to make it correct we should
always uh we should always entertain
that so
yes thank you there does anyone else
wish to talk speak on the
amendment seeing
Shu I'm sorry madam chair I was raising
my hand on a different
isue at the moment we're discussing
Amendment
206 which simply as I look at it instead
of saying CFR section 107 .53 it just
says section 107 which is the
Vehicles motion to adopt Amendment 0206
H the clerk will call the RO
representative
Roy yes clerk was yes representative
uh representative
yakovich yes yes yes representative leus
yes representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey yes repes
representative
naso
yes representative
Judy okay
we you think perfect representative
Schmidt
yes representative
Schultz yes representative fellows yes
representative funno
yes representative Gro yes
representative O'Brien yes and the chair
yes 190 on the amendment the amendment
is adopted you have a further motion
representative Broda yes thank you chair
Madam chair I
am make a motion of a to pass as with
Amendment on House Bill 298
this um bill
um allows that's that's not an
order okay I just made my motion I will
second her motion thank you
representative Pearson Roa Pearson do
you wish to speak to your motion
representative BR yes thank you this U
Bill U includes a member of the unman
aircraft industry and that person um is
a certified uh remote pilot
um in the um Aviation users advis
Advisory
Board and which is uh brings New
Hampshire into
age thank you representative
Pearson I
concur thank you is there anyone else
seeing none the motion is ought to pass
with Amendment and the clerk will call
the
role representative Roy yes repres the
clerk votes yes representative Pearson
yes repes representative
yakovich yes representative leus yes
representative algro yes representative
Bailey yes repes representative lanzara
yes representative Santo
naso no
no representative
goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Judy we
representative
Schmidt yes representative
Schultz yes representative fellows yes
representative fno yes representative
groda yes representative O'Brien yes the
chair yes
181 on the bill
consent okay consent it is thank you
very
much and thank you all for be being so
at this time I'd like to open the public
hearing on HB
457 relative to membership and duties of
counil okay I recognize represent to
introduce the bill
[Music]
thank you I'm Carol Maguire representing
marac District 29 Allenstown Epsom and
Pittsfield and House Bill 457 revises
the membership of the youth advisory
Council
and it's looks very straightforward to
me I know the youth advisory Council met
and discussed it yesterday and they have
not had a chance to issue a to agree on
a decision so uh after those people who
are here have spoken I believe the this
hearing will be recessed so that we can
await the testimony of the youth
advisory Council itself and I there are
other people who could answer questions
but
could thank you representative wi at
this time I would like to recognize
Roger
Porter
representa
representative uh thank you madam chair
for the record uh my name is margerie
Porter and I represent present um
Hillsboro district one which is the
towns of Hillsboro antram and
Windsor and I would like to speak to
this bill I have a statement to read
I've also sent you written
testimony it has been my honor and
privilege to have served as the
legislative co-chair of the New
Hampshire legislative youth advisory
Council for the last four years having
first been appointed by Speaker Jasper
and then by Speaker
shirtliff prior to that I assisted
representative Carolyn gargas for two
terms when she served in that position
she also was appointed by speakers of
both parties which is as it should be
because the council is
nonpartisan I'm extremely proud of the
work the council has done during my
tenure the young people are motivated
and work hard under some difficult
restrictions to perform the job they are
tasked with to advise the legislature on
issues of importance to the Youth of the
state attendance at meetings has
improved several well-planned and
informative public forums have been held
more members have testified before
committees and more statements of
support or opposition to various pieces
of legislation have been sent to
legislative committees in fact in 2020
the council testified or sent written
statements on 13 pieces of legislation
before us this despite everything coming
to a crashing halt for them in March due
to the
pandemic that is why I was so dismayed
to learn the sponsors of this bill did
not contact me or any council member
before filing this bill in fact we only
learned about it when a council member
doing his work reading over the lists of
LSi
brought it to our
attention there are changes to the
statute that could be made to help lak
do its work more effectively in fact I
had hoped to do that next year when
things are more back to normal
unfortunately none of those helpful
changes appear in this
bill I have provided the committee with
lengthy written testimony explaining how
things have been done up to now so I
won't go into the details here I just
want to address several aspects of this
bill currently council members are
appointed by the governor the Secretary
of State the president of the Senate and
the Speaker of the House only once that
I know have has any of these appointer
found a candidate on their own that was
governor Hassen back in
2015 it has been left to the house
member who serves as the legislative
co-chair to seek out candidates and make
recommendations for appointments to
these respective
officers this is time consuming work I
have detailed the process we use in my
written testimony but being somewhat
familiar with the amount of work it
takes the speaker's office to fill
vacancies on the many committees and
commissions we create I know they will
not be eager to have the responsibility
thrust upon them to be brutally honest
even though lak was the light of my life
for four years it is now low down on the
totem pole for the
appointer they were always most pleased
forward another section of the bill we
already provide written test statements
and
testimony on issues that are important
to council members we provide an annual
report two and I've have attached the
last four to my written testimony for
your perusal and I do need to tell you
that the report for
2018 um I sent twice because I wasn't
sure it was getting through and the word
version is not a complete version please
look at the pdf
version organizing and presenting a
public forum on the issues they find
important is in my opinion one of the
most valuable duties the council now
perform forms they enjoy the work they
are eager to do it and they learn so
much by teaching others I am not sure
why we would want to eliminate it but
most baffling to me is the provision on
page two line 13 which reads prepare and
execute programming to encourage job
growth in New
Hampshire lak is here to advise us on
the things that are of importance to the
Youth of New Hampshire
prior to their first meeting of the year
they are asked to talk with their peers
about what's important and to bring
their list with them they do we may not
like the issues that they bring to us or
agree with their positions on them but
it all comes from them representing
their
peers imposing our own desires and
issues on them defeats the very purpose
of the council's
existence as I mentioned earlier on
there are changes that can be made to
help the council work more
effectively I am asking the committee to
recommend retaining this bill so that
the youth council members the new
legislative co-chair and others who have
been involved can be can have input and
I know that the council members have a
lengthy list of suggestions that they
would like to offer to you so with that
I will close my testimony and I'll take
questions if you would like thank you
thank you representative um does anyone
have
questions um representative
Marino
oh oh he's wishing to speak oh okay does
questions there being none thank you
representative Porter thank you very
uh um yes Mr chairman I wish to speak on
the bill is this an appropriate time I'm
I'm not a legislator I'm a member of the
public
yeah go ahead okay uh well uh thank you
very much um Mr chairman um like I said
I'm not a representative although I
appreciate you trying to give me a
promotion just a second ago um my um my
name is Doug Marino um I uh used to
serve on the legislative youth of
advisory Council uh when I was in high
school um and so I just want to uh speak
very briefly on this bill um I really
appreciate um representative um Porter's
testimony um during my time on the
council which was uh uh well over
probably six years ago now um we had a
similar Bill uh proposed uh while I was
on the council and uh much like this
time um the sponsors did not uh consult
us beforehand um I I do think that um
you know it's worth having a
conversation about making certain
changes to lak but I think that it is
very important to include the council
members in that
conversation um I I fully support
representative Porter's um position that
the bill should be retained um and I
also do have significant concerns in
particular about the um the idea of
eliminating um the um section of the
statute uh relative to public
forums um I think that that that's uh
something that um is very important for
the council it's something we took a lot
of pride in while I was on the council
trying to hold public uh forums to
engage with the public on the issues
that matter to them and have that inform
our priorities as well so I would
strongly urge you to to keep that
provision in place um and then um other
than that I I I hope that um the council
gets a chance to weigh in um and I go
representative Porter's testimony thank
you so much for your time thank you Mr
Marino does anyone have any questions of
Mr
Maro uh representative
Shu thank you Mr chair thank you for
your testimony Mr Marino uh with
reference to the public forums that you
mentioned uh when you served on this
group did you find that the public
forums tended to be other students that
were interested enough to bring issues
forward at
those than thank you for the question
representative and yes um I um I don't
um uh remember exactly what the
breakdown was but um if I recall
correctly a significant portion of the
people who participated were other young
people who wanted to um get an idea of
what issues we cared about and express
their in issues that they're interested
in even though they weren't
members yes that's correct thank you
thank you
Marino none thank you Mr Marino for
testifying I
have
a inica
Dondo signed up to testify but I don't
see the name in the attendees if that is
you could you please raise your hand so
twice anyone else wishing to testify on
this
bill excuse me may I interrupt alinka is
having difficulty getting into the page
she is wait trying to figure it out she
said she she signed up and she's not in
the room but she does want to speak
thank
[Music]
you is she perhaps man New
Hampshire she's not she needs to know to
link on from the um from the link on the
C calendar page I'm trying to let her
know that
now okay we'll give it another minute
okay I'm trying to figure it out thank
you
while we're waiting can I ask a question
of the
chair your pardon while we're waiting I
just have a quick question so the we've
inquired as to the official input from
the lak fol and they were still
discussing it and we'll hear back from
them were will there be another hearing
for any of those folks to speak yeah
we're going to recess this bill and we
would reopen it after for more
input thank you and and that gets listed
in the calendar is that correct it will
be thank
you okay at this time I would like to
recognize
right yes thank you so much I apologize
I had a bit of difficulty getting in um
my name is alinka Dondo and I am a High
School Junior from Bedford it has been
my honor and pleasure to serve on the
New Hampshire legislative youth advisory
Council these past years this is the
second year of my term and I was elected
as Outreach coordinator last year and
this year as the youth coach by my peers
I am grateful to be part of such a
committed group of young people they
bring a diversity of opinions and
experiences to the shared goal of
representing youth perspectives to the
legislature increasing Civic engagement
and taking concrete action on the issues
we care about I am testifying as an
individual and not on behalf of the
council given that we were unable to
convene and vote on this bill before
this hearing we have spent time during
our last two meetings deliberating this
legislation and and we have had and
continue to have questions concerns and
opinions surrounding it although we have
not yet adopted an official stance the
points I will bring forth are derived
from the opinions of our members that I
have heard so
far I would like to preface my remarks
by specifying that HB
457 was written without the consultation
of any current NH lak members we were
not involved in drafting it and only
discovered it when looking through lsrs
I believe that the legislation includes
many Provisions that do not benefit the
council or detract from the
effectiveness of its current operations
I also have many suggestions based on my
experience as a member and leader of lak
that I feel would truly strengthen this
legislation and make it more relevant
and beneficial to the
group I will Begin by giving a bit of
context on how our Council currently
operates at the beginning of each year
liak members are tasked with having
conversations with young people across
their communities in order to identify
the key issues that pertain to youth our
first meeting is always dedicated to
Bringing forth our findings and
compiling a list of issues that we
believe impact youth across New
Hampshire and oftentimes the issues that
I will bring forth as a resident of
Hillsboro County are echoed over and
over by the by the council members
across the
state upon sharing our community's
priorities we determine through a vote
which ones are in the majority and will
Garner our Focus for the Year this term
the issues that over whelming least
stood out were Healthcare including
mental health education voting rights
substance abuse gun control and
Environmental Protection they were
raised over and over again by youth
across the state as the issues that
matter most to us um in our age group we
have organized into interest groups
surrounding these issues and between our
monthly meetings each interest group
identifies legislation pertaining to
their topic and brings it to the council
where we debate deliberate and vote we
then CFT statements and testimony to
convey this youth opinion to the
legislature
so people from across the granite state
and engage in legislative advocacy that
surrounds these issues that abundantly
resonate each
year one aspect of this bill that I find
in congruous with our council's current
operation is the regional subcommittee
suggestion as I mentioned before the
same issues and policies tend interest
youth across the state regardless of
their County organizing around these
issues that we identify enables
individuals to focus their energy on
time and researching the areas that they
feel most strongly about while
collaborating closely with members
outside of their
regions a provision of HB 457 that I
also find unnecessary is the provision
that we must prepare and execute
programming to encourage job growth in
New Hampshire I recognize that this is a
very vital issue
however I believe that mandating that
our Council focus on it detracts from
our overall purpose of giving youth
avenues for actions on the issues that
they
identify as being important the council
should be encouraged to take an active
role as this bill says to prepare and
execute programming but I believe that
this should be on the issues that are
identified by members as relevant to
young people including but not limited
to job
growth a possible amendment that some of
our members have brought up in past
discussions and that I wish to suggest
as co-chair is adding youth who are not
students but rather part of the
workforce or taking a gap year as
eligible members I find it important
that we include those who are already
working
full-time I also believe that meeting
virtually should be an option that is
specified within the legislation this
will not only improve the accessibility
of our Council to those who have not
gained driver's licenses or you know
during covid it it provides a safety
measure but it will also allow for
greater Regional diversity as distance
will no longer be prohibitive of
participation as it has been in previous
years this year we have witnessed a
significant increase in attendance given
the fact that members can join from
their own home homes and I believe that
specifying the ability to meet virtually
will be beneficial for future
years HB 457 also strikes the Clause
requiring lak to hold at least one
public forum a year I find that public
forums are truly essential to our
operations as a council given that
forums enable us to fulfill our mission
of Youth Civic engagement we're happy to
organize these and last year we had been
actively planning five forums before
covid-19 had prevented us from making
them happen we Ed these events to hear
from subject matter experts on the
topics that we identify as resonating
with youth across the state and also
hosting these forums is a valuable form
of Outreach many of us on the council
were encouraged to apply because we saw
our peers getting involved in politics
and we were inspired and motivated to do
so as well forums enable us to spread
the word about lak in a way that
resonates with young people and I
believe that striking the Clause around
public forums is
unnecessary based on the legislation I'm
also Unsure how the application process
will be conducted according to the
current wording of HB
457 the president of the Senate and the
speaker of the house will be responsible
for soliciting applications will the
governor and the secet AR of State have
any role in this process as they have in
past years how will students know who to
send their application to I believe that
this should be clarified before the
legislation moves
on another change that the bill creates
would be striking our meeting that we
have in August at the State House
unfortunately we were not able to host
it this year but in the past it has been
a staple of the NH liac our members
always look forward to this opportunity
to see the state government up close
before we begin our terms if health and
safety allows it in future years we
would truly appreciate having a
designated meeting at the beginning of
each term during which we can visit the
state house and meet with our
Representatives we as we have in the
past I believe that incorporating a
substitute for the August meeting into
this legislation is important so this
tradition can be retained in future
years and for future council
members and lastly I just have a couple
other suggestions um one of them being
that it would be best if this bill goes
into effect at the beginning of the next
lak term rather than 60 days after its
passage so it does not append Council
operations midye furthermore I think it
would be beneficial to have an annual
allotted budget towards our Council to
support a zoom license if this would be
possible enabling us to meet online with
more ease and lastly I do know that the
council truly values diversity in school
type socioeconomic background and region
as this bill
emphasizes however I am many of our
members have expressed that we wish to
ensure that all applications will be
considered on a merit basis as they have
been so
far so in conclusion I believe that
there are many beneficial changes that
can be made so legislation surrounding
lak is more reflective of the council's
needs yet HB
457 as it is currently formulated does
not necessarily incorporate these
changes while adding Provisions that I
do not feel are suited to the council
namely I believe that the emphasis on
job growth the regional subcommittee
based restructuring suggestion the
advised appointment process and the
removal of the August meeting and the
public forum requirement are not needed
I feel that by removing important
avenues for lak to have our voices heard
through forums and focusing on the
issues that we identify um as being
important to Youth by removing these
this bill is counterintuitive to the
purpose of the council which is serving
as the link between the youth and the
legislature identifying issues that
pertain to youth and promoting Civic
engagement amongst young people I am
requesting that you retain this bill so
that it can be reintroduced during the
next legislative session incorporating
the changes and input and amendments
that my fellow council members my
legislative co-chair representative
Alexander and I bring forth as the ones
impacted by this legislation I would
appreciate it if we could be involved in
the drafting process so this bill can
make a truly positive impact tailored to
lak's needs thank
you uh thank you very much Mr Rondo and
I really appreciate your
enthusiasm and uh striking as I as I
look at the zoom and I see all of our
daer faces and your your excited young
face I think that's just awesome that
you guys are involved in that um does
anyone have any questions for Mr
Rondo I see representative Schulz thank
you Mr chair um thank you Miss Dondo for
being with us today um I just have a
couple questions if it's it's okay Mr
chair um first how long did you say
you've been involved with with the
council uh yes sure so my first year was
last year on the council and I'm
currently halfway through the second
year of my term great I've been to the
council it is amazing so would
would you rather a new bill with your
suggestions and the rest of the um
board's suggestions would that perhaps
be better
I cannot speak on behalf of the whole
Council um I'm only here representing
myself but I would say that there are
changes that can be made and I believe
that that could happen either through
amending this bill to be more reflective
of our needs or by going through with
another bill um I know that
representative Porter had been planning
on introducing a bill regardless perhaps
next year so I do believe that changes
can be made and I'm open to different
avenues for making them happen I think
as long as the youth members are
consulted in the process um it will be
beneficial what's the saying nothing for
us without us right thank you for your
testimony thank you representative
Shu thank you Mr um I just wanted to uh
say similar to what the chair has
already mentioned that uh I thought Miss
St a very cogent argument and appreciate
your attendance
here representative fellows
thank you Mr chair um Miss Dondo can you
tell us how many students are on the
council and if you think that's a good
number or if there should be more or
less thank you um currently there are 22
members of the council um several of the
members are alternates so they are it's
very helpful to have them there in case
a member cannot attend and um we need to
reach quum by having their vote I
believe that um the current number is a
good one it's big enough to have
geographical representation that's
diverse but also small enough so that we
can work in small groups um as well
through our interest group method um
ultimately I think that I would be open
to both expanding it and keeping it as
it is but I think that um our current
structure in terms of members has been
beneficial thank
you any more questions Mr
Rondo there be none again thank thank
you for coming today and testifying
before us um at this point what we're
going to do is we're going to recess
this hearing until March 8th at 11:00
a.m. so we have some time to get the
[Music]
representative O'Brien I just want to
let you know that we need there will be
a caucus prior to resuming the exec
session on House Bill
274 and
therefore it's 3 o' at we will do that
on our next meeting which is
Thursday thank you madam chair and I
graciously thank you for your
explanation okay we will also be
resuming on Thursday with House Bill
uh to because we didn't finish with the
Amendments on that
one Madam chair would you entertain a
motion on House Bill 357 at this
time uh 356 remind me of the title 357
that was the study committee oh okay
357 yes please what your motion is I
second itl itl by representative Shu
seconded by representative Schulz
representative shood would you care to
speak to your
motion yes um in keeping with uh what
the chair stated uh I think uh iing this
current bill is the proper thing to do
since we cannot officially make study
committees and I trust with the chair's
intimate knowledge of administrative
rules that she will follow through and
allow us to study this issue uh the
issues that some of the issues that were
brought forward when the time is
appropriate
yes well thank you representative
Schultz she said it better than I would
good does anyone else wish to speak
about House Bill
357 I have a point of order Madame chair
yes represent G if we um it all this
bill we can still as a committee work on
this as a committee or do we need we can
work we we you can assign this to us
independently of any legislation or any
um any other any bills is that correct I
think I I believe it okay thank you we
can work on the question because
administrative rules is within our scope
of of
authority we don't need a bill to tell
us to look into it okay so I would um
just so that you know I will support the
itl with the understanding that the
committee will look at that
okay representative Shu I trust you'll
include that in your
blurb yes okay is there anyone else who
357 yes I'd like to say I that I think
uh looking into this will be beneficial
to especially the new members of the
committee who uh are just becoming
familiar with the name of the joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules
or Jael car uh and uh there are a lot of
misconceptions in the body as a whole uh
that uh will be beneficially addressed
by Edna looking at as a committee of the
whole thank you representative
Pearson um thank you madam chair if we
were to itl this even though we perhaps
would have the desire as a community to
do some work on it Would we not then be
prevented from reintroducing this next
year we would be prevented from
introducing another study committee we
would not be prevented from bringing in
a bill on whatever the our study results
in needing that needs fixed yeah yeah
okay yeah fair enough gotcha thank
comments okay seeing none the uh motion
is inexpedient to legislate by by
representative Shu second by
representative Schulz the clerk will
call the role representative Roy yes
clerk was yes representative Pearson yes
representative
yakovich yes representative leus yes
representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey yes representative
lanzara yes representative Santo
naso yes representative goalie yes
representative
sh yes representative Judy we
representative Schmidt yes
representative
Schultz yes representative fellows yes
representative funno yes representative
grodi yes representative
O'Brian yes and the chair
yes 190 does anyone object to
consent all right hearing none we'll put
that on
consent right there Madam chair is there
any reason not to make a motion on House
Bill 94 that's your LIC not at all not
at all i' like to make a motion of ought
to pass on House Bill
94 I'll
second may we please have a refresher on
what house bill 94 is thank you House
Bill 94 relative to synchronizing
renewal dates and
OPC thank you what was the bill number
again I'm sorry 94 sorry who was
speaking sorry it was uh representative
hb994 I'm sorry I can't couldn't hear
you could you speak more distinctly
yes Chris
94 he just answered my question thank
you oh
okay okay representative leus would you
like to speak to your motion I would uh
thank you madam chair um what this does
is well a number of things one is it uh
has the licenses expire on the birthday
of the person who holds the license
rather than having all the licenses at
least for a particular occupation uh
expire at the same time so that'll
spread the workload out over time for uh
oplc I me that's basically how driver's
license uh you know renewal works and uh
you know it'll uh even out the workload
for them there's some transition uh
things in there to get there which I I
think U I don't see a problem with and
that's that's the main thing it's just a
see and for my second I would say that
representative leus explained it
beautifully does anyone else wish to
speak on House Bill
94 Peter
Schmidt yes representative Schmidt thank
you madam chair um let me put
my camera on so you can all see me um uh
I think one of the other very
beneficial aspect is that licenses which
expire in one's birth month and specific
on on one's birthday are licenses
renewal dates that everybody can
remember uh as that we remember with our
driver's licenses as opposed to one day
a year which is made never made any
sense to me in the first place so uh
just the we we it's easy to forget lots
of things but our birthday is not one of
them thank you any is there anyone else
who wishes to go representative
goalie thank you madam chair I just have
um one quick question I'm hoping you can
answer uh when we do these renewals
through um oplc and uh renewal process
taking place are the documents that are
necessary for Renewal such as continuing
ed and the requirements necessary for
Renewal those going back to the board
before a license is
issued for review the requirements for
Renewal are not
changing
uh I'm not sure what you mean by go back
to the
board well there a number of boards that
have renewals that require continuing ed
credits or whatnot for Renewal
yeah uh the requirements that will the
those documents be sent to the board to
make sure they're appropriate before
their license is renewed that's part of
what goes with the renewal license
application that they've completed
continuing
education and uh whatever else is
required I think that's the main thing
that
you you're that you haven't change you
haven't moved your address your you've
completed the continuing education and
you pay the fee of
course is there but my question is if
there is a review of the continuing ed
the make sure it's appropriate for
renewal is it oplc making that
determination or is it going to be the
board that sees that documentation for
generally the board
does all right as long as that's going
back to the board and uh that's part of
this process I will support
it I will say that there's no change
this bill does not change the renewal
process other than the
date the the current requirement ments
for continuing education and who who
reviews it is not
changed thank
comments seeing none the motion is ought
to pass by representative leus and the
clerk will call the role representative
Roy
yes clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative yakovich yes
yes representative leus yes
representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey yes representative
lanzara yes representative Santo
naso yes representative
goie yes representative
sh yes representative Judy a we
representative Schmidt yes represent
ative Schultz yes representative fellows
yes representative funno yes
representative groda yes representative
O'Brien yes and the chair yes
consent seeing none we we'll put it on
consent
does anyone else have a motion on some
Bill that they think we got ought toh
decide
today no one else does I'll move ought
to pass on House Bill
302 which is the creation and use of
you all
right you I don't wish to speak on the
motion representative Schmidt do you
wish to speak on your
straightforward does anyone else wish to
Pearson thank you madam chair uh the I
only have one concern and it's really
not earth shattering here it's simply
the simple concern that I have is that
electronic records require electronic
programming and as I've worked for the
government now for 25 years we have
records that we cannot access because we
either no longer have the program to
open said records or we lack the
institutional knowledge of the
appropriate way to log into said
records that that is a very real problem
here
and you know I'm I'm certainly hopeful
that you know this this bill certainly
would allow and I don't see any
prohibition of backing things up on in
other formats whether it be microfilm or
something else but it's just uh it's not
really going to affect necessarily I
suppose the way I vote it's just it's
just something that we have to
remember that's
all thank you that's a very valid
concern I know NASA has hundreds of
thousands of hours of data that's no
longer
accessible does anyone else wish to
well
IES I I'll just say that paper records
um there there some paper records out
there they're written on something
called
Papyrus um and they're WR written
sometimes in in uh in um linear a and
Linear B and or they're written in
what's called bodon I think is the name
of the term which means as the as the ox
plows going back and forth and back and
forth not the way we read left to right
then left to right then left to right or
the Japanese read top to bottom top to
bottom um so they're all kinds of
written records which are basically
inaccessible or you have to be uh
extremely
skilled try reading old German script um
records that are written in that these
are all things that are written either
on paper or uh or very similar
substances which are extremely difficult
to access um but uh one of the things we
have to do is uh develop something which
is um more universally available and not
go away from it so
obviously it it easier said than done I
know thank you representative scitec
representative Schmidt have you seen my
first teaching certificate you might
want it's in Linear B yes you like to
look at it l written in Linear B is
it
later all right does anyone else wish
repres like us um do you or anyone else
know to what extent they're already uh
standards that have been created and me
this mentions that they're uh the
Secretary of State and cooperation
Department of Information Technology and
administrative
Services um was shall determine whether
and to what extent now it says mayate
standards if we pass this um do you know
if there are existing standards and are
are they generally used and do you know
anything about
I do know that municipalities are using
electronic records of various sorts but
I don't know what standards they're F
this is permissive right this is
permissive
permissive maybe one there a study
into is there anyone else who wishes to
speak on House Bill
302 seeing none the motion is ought to
pass and cler R representative Ro
yes clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes with
concerns I'll make a note representative
yakovich
yes representative L leis
yes uh representative Allegro yes
representative Bailey
I representative
yes representative goalie yes
representative
Shu yes representative Judy we
yes representative
Schulz yes representative
fellows yes representative fun no yes
represent reprentative groa yes
representative obrien yes and the chair
yes 19
no okay the vote is 19 to zero does
anyone object to
consent
see excuse me did someone
object
speak all right that's the ghost in the
Madam chair if there are no amendments
to HB 72 I don't think there are I'd be
happy to um move a to pass on what HB 72
that's the building codes yes there are
there there will be an amendment I
motion unless someone else has another
motion
okay we will yes representative fellows
um if you're willing to do this um I'll
make a motion for
HB
345 with an amend I first make a motion
on an amendment to that
345 that's that's a mushroom mushrooms
oh yes all right let's try 345 I'll
second
that motion is yet so first I'd like to
make an motion for an amendment and the
amendment number is
202-
0239 H that's the that's the um one from
today it's slightly different than the
one that sponsors showed us I'll second
that all right one moment while I get
cleared do you wish to speak to your
motion yes what was the amendment number
the amendment number is
0239 and it was um sent out to you by
Miriam uh just this morning so we don't
have it in hard
copy you you're changing the definitions
right those there's three three
definition changes okay um yeah just
just
changing one um just changing the
definition of mushroom the two things
under that are identical it's just that
the mushrooms is being slid into a slot
um not at the end so it's just
renumbering the other two if if you
don't have this amendment the the
difference between this and the first
amendment is that it just um
changes a couple of the words I think
the first one s said mushrooms means the
fruiting body of a fungus and this one
says mushrooms mean the fleshy Spore
bearing fruiting body of a
fungus and the reason for this update is
that there was some
confusion particularly for the general
public about
chaga which is a
hard
substance looks like charcoal that grows
on a tree and people um pulverize it and
they use it for tea and um the wild
mushrooms we're talking about or
something that you throw in a pan and
cook so this definition um makes it
clear that chaga is completely outside
are there question not only not only
that but this uh line four is could be a
pretty pretty terrific insult you fleshy
Spore bearing fooding body of a
top does anyone else wish to speak about
um representative fellows I just wanted
to I'm looking at the
amendment and in section
one we have tier one mushroom and we
have tier two mushroom so are you saying
you want to just combine those tier one
mushroom and tier 2 mushroom into the
one definition of the
mushroom no no no um
there were let's
see the Roman numerals did stop at 8 yes
what we're doing is we're
inserting one more definition but
instead of I'm sorry I'm sorry I see it
I see it excuse me you're right excuse
me thank you all
right anyone else wish to speak on the
[Music]
amendment all right in that case the
motion is to adopt Amendment 0239 H and
the clerk will call the RO
representative Roy yes clerk votes yes
representative Pearson yes
Representative
yakovich
no representative leus yes
representative Allegro
no representative Bailey no
representative lenara
naso
no
representative yes representative
sh yes representative Judy we
representative
Schmidt yes representative
Schultz yes representative
fellows yes representative font no yes
representative groda yes representative
no 14-5 on the amendment the amendment
is adopted represent representative
fellows moves ought to pass with
amendment is there a second second
same people
okay do you wish to speak to your
motion um yes Madam chair um the purpose
of this this bill resulted from a study
commission that we had that involved
mushroom experts um and included Colleen
Smith from the Department of
Health and uh the primary and also
included a chef the primary reason for
this bill is to protect Public Safety
Public Health um we know that mushrooms
are being sold that wild harvested this
has nothing to do with mushrooms that
you buy in the grocery store Wild
Harvest mushrooms were being sold at
farmers markets into restaurants and
while most of the time the mushrooms
that were sold were safe they were not
always safe and some of them were were
even dangerous for people
um the other thing that was important is
that um right now A restaurant is not
allowed to serve wild mushrooms because
the food code that New Hampshire uses
which is based on the federal food code
says you can um serve and sell wild
mushrooms only if they have been a from
if only if they come from an approved D
source so right now no New Hampshire has
no statutes that identify an approved
Source this process in this bill will
create an an approved source so that
restaurants can serve these mushrooms
and they can be sold at at
um farmers markets we did also hear
stories about how the food inspectors
would go to a rest and sometimes see
that the restaurant has bought had
bought some wild mushrooms and had to
tell them because of the food code that
they had to throw those out and they
they could not serve them so this is
good for business it um Can the
restaurants can make dishes of wild
mushrooms which usually are fairly
do any representative Schultz do you
wish to speak I trust representative
fastidiousness
well it's a good idea but I really it's
not a topic for today but the federal
government is just
everywhere what and it's a good idea
next representative
leas um I agree with what at least about
the the federal government issue I think
the error was uh New Hampshire adopting
the rules from the Federal food code in
the first place concerning
mushrooms um so I'm uh I'm torn on this
on one hand I I really do not want uh
any more licensing on the other hand I
understand the position the mushroom
Harvesters are
in representative yes we didn't have a
we didn't have a you you're on jail car
we didn't have a choice did we we must
these restaurants could not
serve I'm not sure it was obvious to me
it wasn't obvious to me at least when it
came to Jael car that we were adopting
that much I
mean well it still seems like a good
idea
speak yes Madam chair represent
peon thank you as a uh as a former
professional pizza maker I've seen uh
many a pie ruined with the uh with the
fungus and the F4 mentioned bill but I
am going to support this because I
recognize the struggles that especially
at the farmers markets with the people's
desire to do the right thing and and
lacking uh subsid of
direction to do so so I'm I'm going to
this is there is there anyone else who
wishes to speak representative font
now thank you madam chair yes I too when
when we first heard this bill uh in the
last session was very uh reluctant
because I thought it was you know
overreach of
legislation uh however through all the
testimony from the restaurant tours and
mushroom
Growers I now view it more as enabling
legislation than restrictive
legislation that it it allows the
restaurants and the farmers markets to
uh to do something legally that they've
probably already been doing so I will
support
it
else yeah I'm very torn on this because
I think the license is is ridiculous but
on the other hand we have federal
regulations that are even more
ridiculous that are restricting what we
can do and so it's a question of how
we how we accept
that anyone
else sure yes representative
sorry so are we going to support our
Merchants our Harvesters our restaurants
or are we not this bill lets us to
I would just like to add it also creates
jobs we heard um testimony from somebody
who gets a to several people who get a
substantial amount of income from
harvesting and selling wild mushrooms or
would like would like
to thank you representative scitech
representative fellows we are not a
chamber of commerce we're doing this
thank you representative
scitec does anyone else wish to speak on
345 all right seeing none the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment and the
clerk will call the role representative
Roy
no the clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative yakovich
no Representative leus no representative
Allegro no representative Bailey no
representative
lenara yes representative Santo
naso
no representative goalie yes
representative
Shu yes representative Judy we
representative Schmidt yes
representative Schultz
yes representative
fellows yes representative funno yes
representative
groa yes representative O'Brien yes the
12-7 in
favor all
right representative fellows you will be
the I think you got interrupted but I'm
I'm I will write the majority
report yes thank you is there going to
Report no consent calendar right it's
not on consent no and I can't write the
minority I'll do it okay representative
minority is is there a due
date at your earliest convenience and do
can you tell me if I send it to you or
to send it send it to me please thank
any other bills that we think we
tonight I'm out of counter
ah I think most of the rest look like
they have uh have amendments
coming unless you want to discuss con
Constitutional Amendment
governor I don't see a lot of interest
so I think pause okay oh you do have
interest representative
pearon I mean I'm okay with it it's I I
think you know the the the more bills we
can process the better this is going to
go for us this year but sure either
way well it's going to take a while
because I I'm going to speak on this in
in
opposition won't won't be
brief I I have
concerns representative Pearson what
would your motion
be I'm I'm not sold on this
idea you're sitting on all right then
this bill is not ready for CRI I'm not
sitting on the side I am I'm not in
favor of of the concept of a lieutenant
what I missed that you said you're
opposed to the bill as
written rect moo that is correct I am
opposed to this number seven as it is
written
um I also have a technical
issue that um the what I see on the web
and what I print out it's not drafted
correctly not all the the inserts are
not bold after you get onto page four so
I think that could create a
problem
I I'm not in favor of the bill at all
does someone have a motion presumably of
itl my comments
itl I Schmid Schmid moves itl all right
I
second unless somebody else wants to
wasn't representative Pearson first in
line oh sorry representative Pearson
would you like the honor of seconding I
would I would gladly share that with you
you know it's
it's I'm not gonna lose sleep either way
it doesn't matter as a test before we
spend a lot of time discussing this is
there anyone I is there anyone who is
going to definitely vote against the
against so it sounds like it's going to
be unanimously
itl
U I'm sorry madam chair did you say that
there was it was unnecessary for lengthy
debate on this is that what I heard no I
was just going
to ask if anyone is definitely going to
vote against it to see how much time we
should devote to it if everybody already
agrees with representative Schmidt then
we can spare ourselves I was gonna vote
for I mean vote against itl but I had no
desire to make a
speech I repeat that please you uh we're
having trouble with with hearing you
representative Schulz you're saying
sorry I I'm going to
speech okay well I we can appreciate
that very much all right uh if no one
case I can't cut off debate so if you
object please say so but otherwise I'll
just ask the clerk to call the role
Speak now or for forever hold your pece
forever or at least for the next
this the next two
minutes thank you representative Schmidt
all right no one has objected so the
motion is itl by representative Schmidt
on cacr
7 and I just ask for a clarification who
the official second is Ruda represent
Bara thank
you okay I call the role representative
Roy yes clerk putot yes representative
yakovich
no what was that please no no no okay
representative leus yes representative
Allegro yes representative da yes repres
representative
lanzara yes representative Santo
naso yes representative goalie yes
representative
M it's sou let's go no no no I say
yeah representative Schmidt yes
representative Schultz
no representative
fellows yes representative funno yes
representative Gro yes representative
O'Brien yes and the chair
yes looks like
163 all right this will not go on the
consent
calendar and is there going to be a
Minority
Report I can write one you will write a
Minority Report all right thank you oh
okay when do you need these
by I'm sorry Peter when do you need them
by Carol as soon as
possible oh her motion will be ought to
pass what what uh I have to rep when the
the author is representative Schultz but
the motion that she would make is ought
to pass is that correct representative
Schultz you're recommending that this
ought to pass
[Music]
while we have everybody on would the uh
all the members of the Republican caucus
please send me an email with your
updated phone numbers and email
addresses thank
[Music]
you
all right
um I think I think I've had enough for
one day we will resume on
Thursday and due to deadlines we will
complete the executive session on house
bills 591 and
247 that's our last day before the
deadline thank you all I'll see you
Thursday can I just ask a question to
you